Streaming...
Oh!
Oh, I think it's... Okay.
I, uh...
I, um... Wait, hold on.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, I'm all over the place.
I, uh, moved some stuff around.
I moved some stuff around today, so...
My setup is all wonky right now for me.
Hello!
Wait,
hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry, I'm all turned around today.
Okay.
Oh, if I move...
And then...
It, uh...
Stops the music.
Sorry.
Oh, there we go.
Hi, guys!
It's me, Minto.
Actually.
Yeah.
Welcome.
Oh, why am I so... Why do I feel so weird?
I didn't think that, like, changing my setup would make me feel...
So naked.
Like, I feel like I'm...
I feel like when I'm, like, not streaming from home, I feel so strange.
Because everything is different for me.
Not for you guys, but for me.
So it's making me...
Making me feel weird.
Anyway.
I didn't... I didn't...
I technically didn't clickbait, so...
There we go!
Welcome to...
The inn.
The inn?
The inn of...
Saneness.
No more lilac?
No, because you guys are weird!
Because you guys always say...
Oh, I don't like Minto anymore.
I only like lilac.
No!
Because you guys are weird about it!
That's why!
No more!
Anyway.
Yeah, so...
This is a...
Indie horror game that I...
Saw some other creators that I follow play, and...
I was like, oh, this seems pretty decent.
It's kind of, I think, a long... A bit of a longer game.
But I want to finish it in one go, so...
We'll do that.
And... Okay, guys.
Okay, that's... That's enough!
I shouldn't have even...
Brought it up then.
If you guys are not even gonna pay attention to what I'm saying!
Anyway.
Okay.
Cool.
What was I saying?
I want to play a game.
So we'll play a game.
Sorry, I feel very...
Out of it today.
I don't know why.
I feel very out of it.
I woke up feeling very tired.
I feel very tired now.
But I just want to play a game.
Thank you for the Akasho ball!
Do it for the wisp?
Bring out lilac.
No.
Woke up on the wrong side of the bed?
Maybe.
It's one of those things about being...
Like, it's one of those...
I guess it's like a first world problem about being a...
A content creator, right?
Because it's just like...
Oh, if I'm having an off day...
I have to like just kinda suck it up, you know?
It's like...
Otherwise, my feelings will make me...
You know...
Have less fun.
So it's just one of those things where it's just like...
I'm broadcasting myself everyday.
So it's like...
If I'm having an off day, it's like...
I gotta put on my big girl panties and say whatever.
So...
It's just like the service industry.
True!
Yeah, right?
My granny panties.
Oh, yes, son.
My panties.
That's what grandmas say, probably.
No, I think I'm okay though.
I'm not gonna be like so grumpy.
I think it's... I don't know.
Like I said, I cleaned.
But...
Since I rearranged my desk, I feel so weird.
Okay, I'm gonna have to move this.
Hold on.
Oh my god, it's driving me insane!
Okay.
Oh wait, I can't move it now.
Okay, I'm just not gonna touch this part.
I usually...
Touch while I'm on stream.
But I moved it to the other side of my desk.
And now it's bothering me.
Alright.
So yeah, this game is...
Like I said, it's a little longer.
I've watched a little bit of when people played.
It's like about...
I don't...
You go to this hotel...
You go to this hotel and then...
The end of the world happens.
And then you acquire a Hot Goth GF.
So yeah.
Kind of awesome, if you ask me.
Highly appreciated.
Thank you.
Hot Goth GF.
That's all I need to hear.
Yeah, so let's check it out.
But also like...
I think there's something wrong with us.
I mean, of course.
But...
We can't see people's faces.
For some reason.
Save me, ghost girl.
The Sanity...
Wait, it's actually called Sanity Inn?
Why would you name it that?
Walk to the hotel manager.
This is an inn?
Aren't inns supposed to be like...
Quaint?
And...
Dainty?
Aren't they supposed to be like a little...
The inn.
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Oh, I'm tiny.
I'm so small.
Hello, are you the manager?
I want to rent a room.
Could you please wait?
I'll be free soon.
Okay.
Okay, how do I get out of the dialogue?
I'm waiting.
Okay.
Looking at my toes.
I want to press the bell, but I can't reach it?
Try clicking?
What do you think I'm doing?
I'm clicking?
This guy is hacking into something.
Listen to him go.
I just started the game.
Oh wow, what a lovely chandelier you have.
At the Inn Sanity.
I mean the Sanity Inn.
I pressed space, it worked.
You look like an angel.
Okay, it's space bar.
I love your compliments.
Give me another one.
That's how I speak too.
I wonder what tone she used when she said that.
Was it flirtation or sarcasm?
Wait, so he like actually...
He can't hear.
It's like an actual video.
Like a dialogue box pops up for him.
Like a video game.
The guy is in the game.
Oh my gosh, this is Sword Art Online maybe.
Your husband is a complete idiot.
To leave such a beauty.
Let's not talk about that.
Today we'll forget about him.
And your wife.
I'm gonna keep listening.
This is tea.
Of course.
Are you okay?
The whole town is having nightmares.
Are they bothering you too?
Not anymore.
Good.
I'm glad they've stopped.
Because now we can...
Can what?
My nightmares continue.
Oh, it's just that they don't bother me anymore.
As long as there's wine and you nearby.
Damn.
This will be a wonderful evening, my angel.
This is like...
This feels like actual like...
Aliens pretending to be human speech.
Right now.
This place has to invest heavily into the decor to make up for the fact it was named the Sanity Inn.
Maybe the last...
The person who made it, their last name was Sanity, right?
That would make sense.
Why does it always come back to NTR?
I don't know.
Oh, wait a second.
Your nose is bleeding.
Young man, please come over.
Oh, I'm the young man.
Welcome to Sanity Inn.
What can I do for you?
I need a room for one night.
I like the dialogue.
The way the options show up.
Certainly.
Can I have your name, please?
It doesn't matter.
That's not how these places work.
John Smith.
What if I say...
What if I say I'm going to give you...
Clearly, I want to be anonymous.
I'll leave a tip and you write nothing.
You are very generous, Mr. Thompson.
The manager is corrupt.
Oh my god.
The registration will take just a minute.
Meanwhile, I would like to tell you about our hotel.
Sanity takes pride in its restaurant, which is located on the roof of our esteemed building.
We also recently opened a swimming pool.
This place of this caliber and size only just recently opened up a swimming pool?
You are looking at me strangely.
Is everything okay?
Okay, rude.
Crap, he picked up on it.
It's none of your business.
Everything is fine.
Please continue.
Are you sure?
Go a little further.
There you will find the elevator.
Go up to the third floor.
The room number is 302.
You can contact the front desk, restaurant, or security by phone.
And sir, here is your key card.
Welcome to Sanity Inn.
He's the real hentai protagonist.
This is how they should do it instead of having their hair really long, right?
Hotel key card!
Oh, they're gone.
No!
My...
My couple!
Was she there before?
Oh my god, what is she doing just standing there?
She scared me.
I don't think this game is from...
I don't think it's necessarily super scary, but it has like a good atmosphere.
From...
What I got from it.
So...
Yeah.
I should say hi.
I can't go over there.
Sometimes the mystique is the allure, right?
She's shrouded in shadow.
She's got that hourglass figure.
You know what?
I don't even need to meet her.
I know she's my soulmate from afar.
Horse.
And...
Deer.
A lighthouse?
Let's go to our room.
302.
Call the elevator.
Ping pong!
Oh, is this the swimming pool?
Maybe we go later.
Third floor, please.
Hold the door!
This can't be real.
Why am I hearing her?
Is something wrong?
Is there something stuck in my teeth?
Oh, young miss.
Do I be weird about it?
Sorry.
Marriage.
Oh my god, the romantic music playing.
I don't think this is a horror game, you guys.
Be weird about it.
I heard your voice.
This place was huge.
How is it only five floors?
I don't understand.
Fourth floor.
Yes, ma'am.
How's the audio, by the way?
I feel like she's a little quiet.
Why am I hearing her voice?
Something has changed.
She's the one.
Oh my god, forget that silhouetted woman.
Forget the silhouetted woman.
This is the woman of my dreams.
I don't know.
I couldn't go outside very often.
Okay, if I say that, she'll definitely know something's wrong with me.
I don't know.
Okay, I feel we're very passionate about movies.
We said the most here, right?
Your bedroom?
Stop!
We have to win her over first.
Oh my gosh.
The matching, like, oh my god, single leg...
And then the arm...
Oh my god.
It's just such a good fit.
We must woo her.
I don't know.
Maybe the movie theater.
She seems like... Goth girls like movies, right?
Swashbuckling?
So she's also a weirdo.
What do you mean?
I've never been to a movie theater before.
What's swash...
Swashbuckling.
You guys, she's perfect.
Oh.
Yeah.
I hope we meet again someday.
I knew it was love when I heard her voice.
I mean, sure, it's the only one I can hear.
Thanks for the advice.
Oh my gosh, when she's illuminated by the fluorescent lighting of the elevator, she looks like a true angel.
No!
My queen!
Check into room 302.
So what do they do with the rest of the building if there's only five floors?
Also rude.
Blocking the entire way here.
We got Elvis.
302.
Oh god!
Oh, you scared me.
Young man, are you checking in too?
Yes, sir.
Be careful.
It's a sinful place.
Trust no one.
Hey, young man.
Do you trust people?
I'd like to say mostly yes.
We're a glass half full type of person, I think.
Trust should be placed in God alone.
You'll understand this... I keep biting my tongue recently.
You'll understand this soon enough.
Okay, good thing my room is...
this way, I think.
He's blocking that.
311.
Okay, this place is not as fancy as I once believed.
I thought that was like a man sniffing her.
That's just her bird.
Hear the music?
Oh my god, she's giggling.
I trust people, I do not trust dudes with mosaic face.
Oh, we're all the way at the end of the hallway, I think.
Let's just run down there.
Alright, 302.
That's me.
Unlock the door.
There we go.
Home, sweet home.
Finally.
Oh, that's...
I got achievement for checking into my room.
All that's left is to unpack my things and get ready.
I'm... Oh, there we go.
I'm trapped.
There we go.
Unpack my things.
We got a soundtrack too?
Put my razor?
I bought it on the way here.
It's sharp enough.
It will do?
Like...
What razors are supposed to do.
Guys, are we the baddie?
Are we gonna go on a murdering spree?
Wow, they only give us shampoo, no conditioner?
It'll do.
Oh wow, we got like a whole suite.
Put my backpack.
Who would have thought that all my things would fit in one old bag.
Oh, we're definitely gonna murder people, I think.
Wow, what a view.
Wow, it's kinda nice though.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I feel like I'm in a film noir.
It's a full moon night.
The clouds are moving at a pace.
And me, I'm thinking of that gal back home in town.
The gal I left behind.
Because she died.
Every detective needs a tragic backstory.
But I'm here to start anew.
Oh, nevermind.
This one doesn't fit the vibe.
Oh, we can change the station.
Oh yeah, this is good.
This is good.
Back to my monologuing.
And here in this old town is a case.
A case that only I can solve.
And why can I only be the one to solve it?
Because I'm secretly the murderer.
But you don't know that yet, neither do I.
It's a whole Dr. Jekyll, Mr. Hyde situation.
And me, I'm Mr. Hyde.
But you won't find me hiding.
What else do I have?
I put away all my stuff, apparently.
And you want a bottle of water?
Well, they assume that I got this room with two people.
Do I have a coat?
What else do I need to put away?
Toilet paper?
Sounds like a cold case, bro.
No!
The case is hot.
Sizzling, even.
Just like the bacon she used to make me in the morning.
The day before she died, she made me that bacon.
And then I ate it.
And it was crispy.
But then she slipped and she fell and the pot of bacon bonked her on the head and she died.
And the reason I couldn't hear her was because I was too involved in the job.
I'm murdered to my... wait, not murdered.
I'm married.
I'm married to my work.
Oh, this is my... oh, put the photo.
Oh my god, it's her!
This is her.
This is her right before sizzling up some good bacon.
I've already started to forget what she looked like.
It's good that I still have a photo.
What is that beeping?
No, my music.
What's happening?
Oh, listen to the radio.
Oh, attention.
We interrupt our program to bring you an urgent message from the Center for Disease Control and Prevention.
Uh oh.
A temporary quarantine is being declared in the city due to a natural gas leak.
Would that require a quarantine or...
You may observe power outages in some areas.
Specialists are already working on solving the problem.
A gas leak... a Resident Evil-esque announcement.
Do not leave your homes and do not go outside.
Stay calm and follow official announcements.
Also, don't light any cigarettes.
The situation is under control.
A citywide gas leak.
Something doesn't add up.
Cutscene.
Earthquake?
Oh, what the hell?
Oh god!
The moon fell!
What?
I don't think that's...
This is a pretty big gas leak, you guys.
Oh, jeez.
Oh no!
The car is going off.
It's a nice touch.
The clouds are going at like a million miles per hour.
Everything is under control, everybody.
A scream.
I need to check what happened.
I don't think we do.
I don't think we need to check.
Oh my god.
Hello?
Do I go towards the purple light?
It wasn't Goth GF, was it?
Oh my god.
Music.
Hello?
Where are all the lights off?
Oh god, I'm not going down there.
Hello?
What's going on here?
I need to get out.
Yeah, we do.
Let's leave.
Hello?
If you want to live, go back to your room and lock the door.
Do you understand me?
There is a dead body in here.
I don't have time for it, kid.
Just do what I say.
Go back to your room, lock the door and don't open it.
No matter what anyone says.
Oh shoot.
Damn.
Oh my god, they got him good.
Oh, what's this?
Bloodstained note.
It seems that the man I saw in the lobby was here.
Oh no!
What happened to him and where is that woman?
Oh my gosh, it's the couple from the lobby.
My angel, I'm waiting for you at the hotel today.
My wife has gone to her parents, so we have the whole weekend.
That's so silly.
Wee woo.
Okay, let's go back to our room.
Just run for it.
Go inside my room.
Oh god.
Oh god, I'm being observed.
From the darkness.
I don't see anyone there.
I need to call the rescue service.
What's their number in this town?
Oh my gosh, even the lights in here.
Everything is freaking me out.
It's scary.
Pick up the phone.
66911.
I think they know.
I feel like they probably know.
Right?
Oh, call.
I feel like they probably know.
Hello.
You've called the rescue service.
Unfortunately, all our operators are currently busy.
Your place in queue is 54.
Please stay on the line or call back later.
What on earth is happening?
Wait, who called me earlier?
Maybe I should have asked.
It seems like the knocking isn't at my door.
Oh, there's knocking?
I didn't hear it.
I need to check out what's going on.
I don't think we do!
Why?
What do you mean we need to check out what's going on?
Just look at the people.
OK, thank goodness.
I hear it now.
Oh, I hear it now.
Oh, 303?
Oh, you are beautiful.
The guy!
Wait, wasn't he torn up?
I love compliments.
Oh!
What is going on?
Day 1.
You have survived to the beginning of the first day.
And we're asleep in the bathroom.
With our razor blade.
You know what?
Fair.
Totally valid actually.
Good morning world.
It was all just a bad dream.
Everything is fine.
Look at the birds are singing.
The sun is shining.
Oh no.
The cars are flipped over.
Yeah, seems like... At least we have water.
Oh, and 007.
Why did I...
Assess to the news.
The quarantine continues.
The city police have received over a hundred reports of attacks by mentally unstable individuals.
Some witnesses claim that the attackers appeared physically deformed.
The Center for Disease Control...
Sorry, have not commented on these reports.
Birthday?
I can't exit out of the game.
Getter Emperor, is it your birthday?
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Getter Emperor.
Meanwhile, the state administration has declared a state of emergency.
We strongly recommend everyone in the quarantine area to stay at home and limit social interactions.
Attention,
the infected can be very dangerous.
I thought it was just natural gas.
The expert committee continues to study the cases of infection, but so far has been unable to identify the source and method of disease transmission.
We will continue to keep you updated.
For now, we move on to our next segment.
It will be songs by your request.
You know, let's just move on from...
Anybody trying to listen to the radio?
For news about what's going on, sorry.
We don't need to continuously broadcast this.
We're just going to play music at this time.
Thank you.
I hope somebody plays...
Smash Mouth.
Somebody once told me...
You're staying alive?
What would you play?
What would be your soundtrack?
The end of the world soundtrack, I wonder.
I'm still standing.
Just yesterday it was natural gas.
Now they're talking about an infection.
Do they even have a clue what's going on?
So true.
So I think we need to call James Bond.
Oh, what's this?
Program foster home.
Foster care.
You are not alone.
Help for orphans, children and adolescents.
Oh, children.
Children and adolescents.
662525.
Okay.
I'll take that.
What about my dead wife?
I hear a lot of popping and stuff.
At least we can hide in the closet, maybe, probably.
Were these always here before?
These cables?
Okay, the music.
Who requested this?
Who the hell asked for creepy ambiance?
007 Oh.
Pick up the phone.
007.
Call.
I did.
Sorry.
This is a watcher.
Are you still alive, kid?
Great.
Watcher?
That's my job title.
I'm in charge of the hotel security.
Or at least I'm trying to be.
The hotel is dangerous.
The problem is that it's even more dangerous outside.
They're saying on the radio that it's a gas leak.
Do you believe that?
No.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm dumb.
What if I say maybe?
Sounds like bullshit to me.
They're hiding something.
And the police aren't coming.
All this smells really bad, kid.
Yeah, because it's a gas leak.
Duh.
I don't know how long we'll be stuck here, but there's a chance it could be for a while.
And don't talk to anyone.
It could end badly.
Is that the sound of my door unlocking?
Wait, hold on.
I want to call.
What was it?
6-6-2525.
Call.
What about our hot goth GF?
I know!
Should I call him again?
I'm not sure.
Foster care support line.
How can we assist you?
Contact my curator.
Hello, I didn't think you'd call.
Happy 18th birthday!
Oh my god, it's our birthday!
I wanted to say goodbye.
Can I return to the shelter?
Something strange is happening here.
Can I go home?
Can I return to the shelter?
Sorry, but you've been declared fully capable, so I can't help you.
Oh my gosh, I can't stop yawning.
Your condition is not as serious as you think.
If you...
Sorry, I'm getting another call on another line.
It seems something happened at your shelter.
I need to sort this out.
Good luck!
Who turned the radio back on?
I didn't turn it on.
Wait, who turned the radio on?
My condition is not so bad, they're saying.
I really sound like...
They're not beating the Film Noir sad detective allegations here.
OK guys, we gotta go find some food.
I don't wanna leave.
OK, we can't go into 301.
Oh gosh, do we even wanna go into 303?
Oh my god!
What's that?
That's all they left.
Oh, what's this?
Bubble love gum.
A chewing gum.
There is a trading card with some romantic phrase on it inside a package.
I'm ashamed to admit it, but I have no experience in this matter.
Might come in handy.
Oh, wait.
In what way?
Wait, do we have like an inventory?
Not that I know how to access.
I think there is a body here, but it's way dark.
Anything?
Any food?
OK, you just got bubble gum.
I got it.
Understandable.
Oh, what's in here?
Nothing, OK.
I don't wanna get jump scared, you guys.
You can eat the person.
Yeah, exactly.
Free food on the floor.
Brains for brunch.
OK, let's 304.
305?
No.
Wait, 304 was... Yeah, no good.
306?
No, OK.
307?
OK.
Well, we went into 308 before.
Oh, we can go in again.
Maybe there is something else.
Wow!
He's not wearing clothes either.
They were in mid-action.
Oh my god, it's kind of awful.
It's just spaghetti, you guys.
Wait, does this room not have a bathroom?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, it's trousers and everything.
I'm a vampire.
I steal their soap or something.
We don't know how long we are going to be here for.
OK.
Let's go to 309?
No.
Oh gosh, what are these?
Are we going to jump scare B310?
No.
What happened to 311?
312?
OK.
Oh, that's right.
It has a weird number.
Young man, over here.
Is it the priest?
It is kind of awful.
Why are you making fun of me?
Would a film noir mint be made sephia?
Maybe.
No, it would have to be...
It would have to be black and white, right?
Made grey.
Yes?
Young man, I need help.
Oh, ignore and move on.
What happened?
I'm not feeling very well.
My blood pressure has risen, but I couldn't get through to the ambulance.
Please help me find the medicine.
It seems he met the mothman.
Oh my gosh.
Got fricked boneless.
Made noir.
Oh my gosh, Kevin.
Why didn't I think of that?
You're so right.
Made noir.
OK.
I don't know.
Do I be like a little jerk?
Why don't you find it?
Do it yourself.
Oh my gosh.
What if I play this as if I'm riding?
What if I play this as if I make all these decisions like I'm riding Metal Gear?
Why don't you do it yourself?
I'm not as young as I used to be.
I can't move fast as you if something happens.
There's a utility room on each floor.
There should be a first aid kit there.
Please bring it here.
It would really help me out.
OK.
I guess we're already...
We're already looking around, so...
Oh, this is the elevator.
Sometimes the game like...
It's an indie game, you know?
But see how there's the light flashes and stuff?
It's freaking me out.
Hello?
Why is it so dark in here?
Oh wait, this room actually has a bunch of stuff.
Damn, they were really living in here.
They have like a whole hamper and everything.
Why are there clothes in the shower?
Artifact jump scare.
Yeah, right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, beans!
What is this?
These are real... Take the pizza!
These are real survivalists over here.
What's this?
What are they building?
Huh?
Wait, what?
What do
you need all that duct tape for?
And batteries.
Search through their bags!
And then they have their...
Huh?
This seems kind of sus.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, here we go.
3, 15.
Nope.
3, 16.
Did you guys hear that?
3, 17.
Oh, nope.
Just kidding.
3, 18.
Oh, 3, 17.
Nope.
It's so dark in here.
Hello.
I don't know why.
Creepy ass paintings everywhere.
Can I open it?
No.
It's so dark.
There is no flashlight I think.
3, 20.
Who just has their doors open anyway?
Hello.
Oh yeah.
We got a muscle head here.
They gotta have food.
Animals!
Life of my cat.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Let's grab... Okay.
We got fruit.
Perfect.
Awesome.
Okay.
Onwards.
Bodybuilder.
Yeah, he's gotta have food.
Another one?
Okay.
This is... I'm going the right way, right?
I guess.
These rooms are actually like each unique which is pretty cool.
Oh, what's this?
More gum!
I'll take it.
Someone was having a... I can't tell if it's a bad time or like a great time here.
Oh wow, there is a lot of beer.
Oh, maybe not such a great time.
Oh, you're gonna have to pay for...
Catty!
Lorps!
She is a... Oh my god!
The Catty!
This guy is a dog.
Take it?
I wish.
It's not time for play though, you guys.
It's time for survival.
It's not time for play.
Wait, which way am I going?
This way?
Oh, that's not so good.
I hear crying.
Oh, I think this is where he is watching me.
Okay, that must be the utility room.
Every time a door opens, it freaks me out so much.
Oh gosh, what's happening to all these rooms?
Surely they did not do all of this in less than a day, right?
This is horrible.
Goth GF was floor 4?
Yeah, she was floor 4.
But he said don't leave, so...
I'm gonna listen to the guy for now.
Ew, smelly, smelly, smelly.
Let's get out of here.
We got donuts?
Okay, is this a door?
What was that?
I can't see anything.
Hold on, I'm gonna see if I can turn the brightness up a little bit.
Nope.
Maybe camera settings?
Wait, gamma?
Oh, we can!
Oh my gosh, thank you.
I just saw the blur part.
Okay, does that help at all, you guys?
Yeah, looks better for me too.
This must be the utility room.
Oh, read a note.
Soggy note.
A fragment from someone's diary.
It's wet to the touch.
They always lock the doors to their rooms.
Why?
I already have the keys.
Probably because they are afraid of someone.
Nothing to worry about.
I'll watch over them.
I'm always watching.
Okay, so about that listening to the guy...
About that listen...
About that listening to the guy that was, you know...
Saying that he was...
He's watching us?
Maybe.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
Guys?
Guys, if we were wise, we wouldn't go over here, right?
Same safe?
It was like a misty man.
What the hell was that?
Water closet.
Inspection.
Is he the one making such a...
Oh no!
A mess of the place?
I guess so.
Good thing he phased out of existence.
We got a room key 328.
328.
Nice.
Someone's in there.
Okay.
Oh wait, we're at 333.
Okay, let's go to 328 then.
Onwards.
Nothing.
Oh, unlock the door, yeah.
Oh cool, so we can unlock some of these?
Oh, not cool.
They like messed up the room and then were like...
I will...
I will lock the door on my way out.
For privacy's sake.
Oh my gosh.
See, things like this, this did not happen in a single day.
I mean that is, you know, a lot, but...
Oh my gosh!
Room...
Service.
Don't mind me, I'm just gonna take all of that.
I'm literally burglaring everything.
Return to your room with the food.
Let's go.
Turn around.
Slowly.
No!
Hello.
Oh god.
I know I just said I'm a burglar, but please sir.
Wrath.
I will ask you questions.
You will answer them.
Understood?
Don't anger me and don't lie.
This could end badly.
Tell me, what were you doing in this room?
This is my room.
I was looking for medicine.
Here's a first aid kit.
No, I was looking for food.
That's the truth.
What?
That makes it more angry?
You said don't lie.
So you were stealing.
Thou shalt not steal.
It's one of the Ten Commandments.
How do I know... Oh my god.
How do I know it wasn't you who killed these people?
How will you prove it?
How will you prove that I did it?
Let's just throw it back in his face.
Look at the bodies.
I wouldn't have the strength for that.
The hotel security guard has access to the cameras.
He will confirm that it wasn't me.
It was a woman in white.
I saw her kill a man.
The one that shut the door earlier?
We didn't technically see her kill anyone.
Three looks like the best option.
The security guard.
That's the guy that's helping us, right?
Do we want to be like, hey, go to that guy?
What if I'm like, I don't have the strength for that though.
I wouldn't be able to tear people in two.
I feel.
Right, this seems logical.
Destroy him with facts.
I've heard what they say on the radio.
People are capable of terrible things.
Alright, here's what I think of my son.
Oh god.
Get that out of my face please.
You're one of the infected.
They said on the radio that you're dangerous.
You got wild and attacked people.
And I need to stop you.
I'm not sick.
I'll give you one chance.
What will you say in your defense?
Uh, radios lie.
Their explanations keep changing.
Why do you believe them?
I don't have a nosebleed.
I don't see hallucinations.
I didn't attack you.
I can control myself.
Uh...
Four?
Yeah, true.
Oh, he doesn't know what to believe.
Alright my son, I believe you.
Go.
Don't be afraid.
Now I'll be watching over you.
Do you have a spare one of those actually?
Oh my god, we made it.
Somehow...
Alright, where was the... 311 is the guy that needs the first aid kit.
That was jawed faith.
Hello, did you see all of that?
Is this entertaining?
What just happened?
Wait, huh?
Actually, did I go down this way?
Wait, I'm lost.
I obviously went down this way.
Where was your CQC boss?
That way was closed before.
Oh, was it?
Oh yeah, to the elevator.
That's right.
But it said go to our room.
I mean, probably doesn't hurt to explore.
Wait, is this a shortcut?
Shortcut?
Oh, the elevator I think is broken.
Oh yeah.
Looking extra cute today.
Yeah, because we went in the... Maybe we went the long way around, I think.
I keep hearing sounds.
It's freaking me out.
Yeah, I think we went the long way around.
So now we go here.
To this guy.
Young man, is that you?
Did you find the first aid kit?
Yes, here it is.
Thank you very much.
I've put together something for you.
You may find it useful.
And beans!
Let's go.
What about your food though?
You collected all available food on the floor.
Oh nice.
Maybe you need something too?
Sorry, I didn't think of it right away.
It's my damn blood pressure.
You can ask me anything.
I will try to answer.
Who are you?
I am a professor.
That is, I was a professor.
I taught biology at the local institute.
I've lived in this town all my life.
Why would he check into a hotel if he already lives in this town?
He's not telling me something.
Yeah, everybody is suspicious here.
Goodness, I'm wasting your time.
You need to get back to your room.
I hope this madness ends soon.
Okay.
I only asked one thing.
That room is so suspiciously dark right now.
Okay.
Run!
I'm just going to run to my room.
To my room!
And shut the door.
Yay!
We made it!
Let's put the food in the fridge.
Nice.
We are stocked!
It's a lovely day.
Turn on the radio.
Anything?
Oh, go to bed.
This is my station, though.
We should have taken some of the clothes.
So we have a change of clothes.
I'm going to fall asleep to this.
Good night, world!
I woke up, I stole food, and now...
I'm going to sleep.
I didn't know this inn had maid service.
Good night.
This room is huge for a bed that is meant for one person.
It is the tiniest...
Bed.
Blood moon.
Who is knocking?
My door?
People?
Please help!
It was a white lady.
Go, white lady, go!
I'm being chased!
Door, open.
Wait, didn't we say that we saw a lady kill a guy, though?
White lady.
Who are you?
Who is chasing you?
Just open the door!
Who is chasing me?
The door to the room slams shut.
I can't get inside.
Please.
Oh, she is so...
She can't even form.
She sounds like she has parasites in her brain.
Open!
Open the door!
Don't open!
Open, open, open!
Open the door for her!
That's so freaky!
Open, open, open, open.
Don't open.
You are not like the others.
Interesting.
That was such a silly...
Oh my gosh.
Now she has a wrath thing.
Oh gosh.
Talk to me.
I want to know more.
What do you see?
Oh, she likes compliments.
I see a beautiful woman.
Is that all?
So...
Banal.
What is that?
What's with the pixelated people?
We have a condition, I think.
Right?
My husband gave me roses for every anniversary.
I always said that I liked violets more.
He couldn't remember.
Oh, what a jerk.
Now my house is empty.
I'm looking for someone who won't leave.
Are you too?
Try to play along.
I was looking for you.
Yes, I'm looking for someone.
I wanted to be alone.
I think she'll be upset if I say that.
If I say I'm looking for someone or...
If I play along...
She might go crazy and kill me, right?
Number two.
I'm looking for someone.
Oh, good.
Someone?
Not me?
Oh, gosh.
I knew she was going to get mad that I wasn't looking for her.
You want to get rid of me.
You're lying.
The one I need.
Please, warm me up.
Liar!
Dreams in the ocean.
I feel you.
She's bonkers, you guys.
Should I trust you?
Prove that you were listening to me.
What flowers do I love?
Violets.
Chrysanthemums, roses, tulips, violets.
You listened.
We won't be alone.
I can fix her.
This is your type, everybody.
You're interesting.
She's got her arms crossed and everything.
I guess, is this like...
I'm confused.
Is this like the reality or...
Is the regular lady the reality?
I'm leaving.
We...
We'll talk again.
I hope not.
Oh, gosh.
She woke me up for that?
Kind of worth.
You know what?
I'd let any lady wake me up in the middle of the night.
Whoa.
Under the sea.
Oh, gosh.
Is this a swimming segment?
Okay, no.
Under the sea.
Darling, it's better down where it's wetter.
Take it from me.
Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
It's suddenly Subnautica.
Ooh.
Wow.
She did say, like, dreams of the ocean, right?
I wonder...
I wonder if when you're infected, you think that...
Oh, wow.
Look at that eel.
Wow.
If you think you're in the ocean.
Maybe if you are infected, you are actually playing Subnautica.
It's pretty peaceful, though.
Yeah, it's kind of nice.
I wish the whole game was like this.
Okay, it's getting a little dark.
I'm gonna... Oh, it's getting...
Oh.
It's not so peaceful anymore, I think.
Okay, that was ruined very quickly.
Oh!
Huh?
Oh, my gosh.
There's... Wait, is that the silhouette lady from the beginning of the game?
Day 2.
Space lady in my bathroom.
You have survived to the beginning of the second day.
Goth GF!
Where is she yelling from?
Here?
Oh, my god.
She's speaking through the walls.
She's in my walls!
You can crawl through here!
Oh, my god.
I can save you.
I hear a voice again.
Is it her?
Hey, who's there?
She's in my walls.
Actually, she's perfect!
Oh, what happened?
Besides, literally, the end of the world happening right now.
Oh!
Maybe be quieter then, if something's at your door.
Okay.
I...
I mean...
Yeah, good luck, lady!
Sure hope you find someone!
Excuse me!
Try calling the security guy.
Yeah!
Okay!
401?
Oh, my god.
No!
I'll wait you here.
No way!
Seems like the smoke... There's no fire anymore, at least.
No way.
I'll wait you, my queen.
Oh, listen to the news.
We are now into the second day of the quarantine.
The situation is deteriorating.
That's not what you want to hear.
We are getting reports of deadly attacks from all over the town.
Our studio has lost communication with the Center for Disease Control.
However, we continue to broadcast.
To all our listeners out there, we stand with you.
You are not alone.
I had a dream last night.
I am not alone.
Oh, no!
I think the news channel is infected!
They're still playing my music, though.
Oh, no!
Hey, I'm gonna call the security guy.
What's his number?
007, right?
Hey, can you go get her or something?
Why is this up to me?
I'm not going there!
Oh, it's you.
The girl on the fourth floor needs help.
If you have nothing better to do, you can take a risk.
I'm busy with something.
So you just like to be nosy.
You just like to be nosy, but you don't want to be helpful?
What's up with that?
Oh, my God.
What if it's the lady we saw before?
I'm guessing we don't need to go back into any of these rooms, right?
Oh, my goodness.
Like, we got everything in these rooms, so...
He's jorking it?
No!
Don't say that!
Oh, my God.
Is that her shadow?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Yes, ma'am.
What's up, Mint?
What's up?
I'm fine.
We're just, you know...
A knock on the door.
Are you okay?
Young man, is that you?
Thank you for yesterday.
I'll be honest, I can count on you more than my own son.
He wants something again.
I better leave.
Why are we so mean to this guy?
What happened to your son?
A few years ago, he fell seriously ill and asked me for help.
I sent him money for the surgery, but it only helped for a little while.
Soon, another one had to be performed, and another.
I had to sell my house to pay for the last one.
And then...
Thanks for seven months.
I don't think he was really sick.
It turned out he was perfectly healthy.
He got scammed by his own son.
Did the surgery help?
We're naive, baby.
I'm riding, I'm riding.
Remember guys, I'm riding.
Did the surgery help?
He was pretending all this time.
This guy is probably like, I'm a professor.
Thank god this bozo didn't go to my school.
Babycore, thanks for the gifted.
He gambled away everything I sent him at the casino.
All that's left of my life savings is $73.
Blackjack.
Oh my god, I rented a room for a couple of days to figure out what to do next.
A homeless pensioner with three loans.
I don't know how to live on, and it's not even about the money.
When a loved one stabs you in the back, you start expecting the next blow from the rest of the world.
Do you understand me?
At least you don't have to stress about the loans now.
We are such a glass half full kind of guy.
Yes, it seems that it's now the least of my worries.
How ironic.
$73, some people have all the luck.
No!
Alright, apparently this lady is walking around here though, so we better...
Well, that explains that, but also I think she's like right here.
Oh gosh.
Is she?
Wait, what is that?
Is that feet down there?
Oh god, I'm scared.
Oh, those are feet.
I had a feeling that would happen.
Let's take the elevator if it's working.
It's not, of course not.
Let's not do that.
Okay, we gotta follow the feet steps.
Maybe?
Which way?
Oh gosh.
Okay, definitely not this way.
How is all of this happening?
What?
Okay.
I don't think this is such a good idea.
Is that her?
I think that's something.
Like, I think if we told the girl that we also had our own thing that we're dealing with, she would understand, right?
Oh my gosh.
I can't see what it is.
It's so scary!
It's not the lady, is it?
Hello, MintFatThumb.
Thank you for the soup.
Soup!
HotGothGF.
Okay, I'm gonna be brave!
Brave!
I'm so glad all of these people are wearing their underwear.
Why did she take off their clothes first though?
Is there anyone in here?
Is she in here?
Madame of the white dress.
Are you gonna wear your...
I got my red dress on tonight.
Oh, what's this?
Just kidding, it's nothing.
What's the point of going in here?
What was the point of this?
Unless she wanted to trap me.
Okay.
The stairs are right here.
Oh god!
You forgot about it.
Oh no, she's angry.
She's furious.
If I don't play along, she might attack.
What did I forget about?
Of course not.
I remember.
I brought it.
I came to talk about it.
What did we forget?
Oh god, what did we forget?
Oh, I'm so sorry.
We're so small.
She's so...
Look at... Oh my goodness.
I remember.
You're not just saying that to get out of it, are you?
I hope not.
Our date.
Restaurant.
White lady jumpscare.
Wine.
And meat.
I'll color the dress in my favorite shade.
Darling, you remember my favorite color, don't you?
Did she ever mention that?
Oh my god.
Black.
Yellow.
Purple.
Green.
Red.
Spend gum.
Oh, we can use our gum!
Of course I remember.
And my favorite color is the color of your eyes.
Violet was her favorite flower.
I don't think it was her favorite color, right?
But also the dress was red.
I don't feel like if we pick one of the ones that...
Maybe we should use the gum.
Maybe.
Riz her up.
I think the gum is like a get out of jail free card, right?
Try the gum.
You always know what to say.
We riz'ed her!
This is like a horror game dating sim.
So messed up.
I need to go.
There's still so much to do.
To prepare.
Stop.
And where are you going?
You're not planning to run away, are you?
We're so small.
The girl upstairs needs help.
I'm going down to... Upstairs?
She's downstairs.
I'm going down to the pool.
I wanted to check out of the hotel.
I wanted to book... Oh yeah!
I wanted to book a table!
You're so thoughtful.
She's back to normal.
It's time for you.
See you at the restaurant.
It's time for me to...
We're going downstairs.
Oh, sorry.
We're going upstairs.
I was right.
Or not right.
Wait, she's 401, right?
401?
Bird?
I knew that was coming.
Look at the blood.
Just like gushing.
Yeah, I knew that was coming.
We have to be quiet here guys.
We have to be quiet.
It's loading.
Oh, saving.
Thank goodness.
Which way?
I wish there was like a... This way to hot girl.
Okay, well definitely not that way.
Oh, nice!
Oh, it's the freak!
The freak janitor!
The girl is hiding something in her room.
Did she steal something?
Is she on the run?
I need to search the room while she's not there.
Huh?
The girl is hiding something.
Okay, good to know.
Can I go into these rooms?
Nope.
Alright.
I wonder... I can't tell how many people occupied this...
I can't tell how many people occupied this hotel.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He is bald!
Alright.
Maybe the next hallway?
Oh, okay.
Probably down this way then, right?
Oh gosh!
Is it this one?
Where is this guy?
These rooms are way too big.
Or this hotel is way too big.
Wow, okay.
I think we should just take all their stuff.
It's pre-packed.
Just take it.
Is there anything in here?
Oh, maybe in the bathroom.
What's the point of letting me come in here if...
They took all the soaps and everything.
Why do they have so many soaps?
I think these guys were robbing the entire hotel.
They have so many soaps.
And slippers.
What is that sound?
I can't open any of the drawers, so...
Is there really nothing in here?
How lame.
Unless in here?
No?
Okay.
Alright, we continue onward.
What is that sound?
Trippy.
Oh,
poor sap.
This floor looks way worse than our floor.
I think we got off lucky.
This floor is... has it pretty rough.
Not gonna lie.
Oh gosh, 401, okay.
Wait, 401?
So not this... well, let's check out the rooms first.
I'm just gonna go from the farthest and make our way back.
Okay.
Alright, well this one is pretty clean.
I think there is someone in there.
What are these photos?
How artsy.
Of you.
Gum!
Yes.
I will rob you of your gum.
What are these photos?
Oh man, they finished their Chinese food.
Could have been for us.
The Riz Gum.
Okay.
Nope.
Nope, okay.
Oh gosh, I think it's down this way, right?
Still no?
Oh my god, these hallways are so long.
It's like the longest... is this a room?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
Okay, well, at least he left.
Alright.
He is definitely down this way.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
So we have to find a way to distract it.
Luckily he didn't hear that.
And he didn't hear that.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many men?
Why do they strip their clothes?
Use the soap.
Why are they all naked men?
I don't understand.
What's going on in this hotel?
Help!
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
God, I need to somehow distract it.
Oh, I need to find the key to the neighboring room.
Maybe I can lure it there.
I need to inspect the corridor.
Oh, okay.
Oh, search the body.
There is nothing here.
One of the bodies should have a key.
Okay.
I think as long as we don't get close to him, we'll be okay.
He doesn't move, right?
He just chills right there.
Alright, cool.
I'm inspecting the bodies.
Nothing as well.
God, I feel sick.
Typical business travel.
True.
Searching the body.
The key must be somewhere here.
Nothing.
Morning, Minto.
Good morning.
Only blood and torn pieces of clothing.
How could he tear them up like this?
At least he leaves their undies.
It's a nudist convention.
Nothing here either.
Nothing here.
Are you?
Oh!
405.
I need to lure the creature there.
My hands are bloody.
What a horrible smell.
Okay, so I don't have to search anyone else now, right?
Let me just check.
No, okay, it won't even let me.
Alright, cool.
Let's go, baby.
Nothing here.
Did Gray Fox go through this hall?
Gray Fox... I think... I don't know.
I think he'd leave them... I think he'd leave them clothed.
Hey, are you watching this?
Huh?
You like this?
You like this show?
I have nothing to lose, I guess, at this point.
Oh my god, is he gonna hear me open the door?
Oh my god.
Okay, we can't open that.
We can turn on the radio.
We can...
None of these open.
Examine the radio.
Rotate the radio.
Is this where I put in batteries or something?
Open battery compartment.
Oh, it has batteries.
Okay.
Extract the batteries?
Put away the radio.
Oh, if I turn the radio on...
Moko-chan?
Is it Moko-chan?
If I turn on the radio right now, he would come running right away and I would die.
So... Is there something?
Examine the... Oh, this is a clock!
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, so then we put the batteries in the clock.
Moko-chan, save me.
Save me, Bao-Bao.
Rotate the clock.
How fast do you think I can get out of here?
Set a timer for... 30 seconds I think is fine.
No, Bao-Bao.
15 seconds, no balls.
Let's do 45.
I'm scared.
Oh god.
Escape from the room.
Okay, I'm going.
Oh my god, am I going to have to hear this the entire time?
Can I just stand here?
I've escaped far enough.
What did I say?
I didn't say fart, did I?
No way.
I gotta close the door probably?
Oh, maybe.
I said that?
I said 45!
Did he go?
Oh, I think he went.
Oh, I don't think I was supposed to do that.
Maybe I was.
Let me in!
Oh my god, hot girl.
Why do you get like the cutest room in the whole hotel?
Oh my god, where is your clothes?
Oh, hot girl smell.
Wow, oh my god, this looks just... it suits you perfectly.
Oh my gosh, we are in a bedroom!
Hello.
Yeah!
Okay, we are packing.
Why haven't you packed him yet?
Oh, so instead you yelled down the... down the vent at me?
Okay.
Okay, anything we need.
Everything.
Where is... oh gosh, we have a timer.
The bag?
What's the bag?
Take the bag.
Take.
Take your clothes.
Take the pizza.
Take... whatever that... take the bag.
Take your other clothes.
What's this?
The church of Jonah?
Take it?
I don't know what that is.
Oh my god.
Okay, hold on.
I'm taking the water.
Nevermind.
Oh, take... open the fridge?
Take everything in the fridge?
Ma'am, why can't you move it?
Ma'am, I'm trying to get us...
Take your clothes?
You're welcome.
What's under here?
Move the... what's this?
Cash.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, I see them.
Look under the bed.
What if I don't take the package?
Collected all the things in the girls room.
Okay.
Can I get up?
Wait.
I can't get up.
Oh, get up.
I'm lying on the ground.
What is this thing?
Take?
What is this?
I'm worried about it.
I think we're good.
I'm ready.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
She's just so calm and cool and collected.
Oh.
Hello?
Shut up.
It's right there.
Please shut up.
Oh my god.
Oh god, girl.
You were the one who told me not to make any noise and you're saying all this stuff yourself.
Girl!
Can't go down there.
I guess we just follow her the whole time, right?
Okay, she doesn't want to run anymore.
That's fine.
She's catwalking.
Hide where?
Hold down the keys to hold your breath.
Oh my god.
Please leave.
I guess I can breathe now.
I guess we're fine.
Did you do that?
Oh my gosh.
Anyway.
No shit.
What?
Let's continue onwards.
Yeah.
Goth GF kind of dumb.
I like her like that.
Oh.
Nice.
Yeah, it's kind of my room.
Sorry for the mess and everything.
Oh!
Sexy music.
Yeah.
Yeah, a lot of food.
Oh, she's praising me.
I have no clothes.
I came here with just a backpack.
Alright, we killed it you guys.
Let's go.
Mi casa es tu casa.
Sorry that I'm asking you just now.
Can I stay with you for a couple of days?
I've nowhere to go.
302 is empty though.
If you don't mind the meat.
Besides, the two of us will be safer together.
Tell me about the package.
Tell me about the brochure.
I didn't get to really look at it.
It said something about Jonah.
Yeah, I guess.
This guy is so nonchalant.
I want to know what the package is though.
Papers and personal stuff?
Tell me about the brochure.
Okay.
Yeah, I guess.
What would Raiden do?
Oh, Gatouyan.
On the bed, I will sleep on the couch?
What?
On the couch, I will sleep on the bed?
No, I'm no fiend.
Actually, I think though Raiden would probably take the bed.
I'm not gonna lie.
Where's the option?
There's enough room in the bed for the both of us.
The game budget truly went to the GF.
Where do you want to sleep, you guys?
Where do you want to sleep?
What if we sleep on the bed and then she's just like...
Oh, sorry.
It was really cold on the couch.
Is it fine if I take the bed?
We can stay there together.
That's kind of the strat.
If I give her the bed, she'll automatically be warm.
One.
You guys are such a gentleman and ladies.
Okay.
She's like, I got a really bad back.
I can't sleep on the couch.
And one more thing.
I completely forgot to say that...
That you love me?
My name is Robin.
Robin.
She's a burglar.
She's robbing me of all my belongings.
Nice to meet you.
And I'm Batman.
Call me Bruce Wayne.
What if we were such a freak?
It's raining.
It's not raining.
We're underwater.
Is she calling?
Is that her?
She's not here.
She's taking a bath.
No she's not.
What?
She wants to go outside.
She's trying to kill me.
Goodbye room.
I hope I'm not actually leaving.
You guys, am I possessed?
Am I infected?
Am I possessed?
Infected?
I don't know what the heck it is.
Do you become possessed?
Do you become infected?
It feels supernatural, but they said it would...
That's not Robin.
Infected.
Maybe hallucinations?
Hello madam.
Lady Galaxy.
I've been waiting for you.
I'm glad you finally came.
It was so scary outside, isn't it?
So many people.
She kind of gets me.
Everyone wants something.
A man with a gun.
Priest.
Do you remember him?
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Thanks for the 20 captain!
Good!
Thank you, thank you!
He was full of anger.
He almost killed you.
Oh, he sounds insane.
He tried to do the right thing.
He was scared like me.
Oh gosh, what would Raiden do?
WWRD
Two or three?
Those are the options that make me seem the nicest.
I don't know if it's the right thing.
Well, he did try to see if I was infected.
And he was killing off the ones that are infected.
So I guess it's kind of fine.
He tried to do the right thing.
And this justifies his actions?
Interesting conclusion.
The Watcher.
He tells you what to do.
He never came out to help.
Neither you nor the girl.
What do you think about him?
All he can do is...
Sorry, I know I keep bringing up Metal Gear and Raiden.
But it's like when you are in a codec with someone...
And when you press R1 versus L1...
And it's like his positive thoughts versus his upset thoughts.
So it's just like, all he can do is command.
That's what I feel about these.
Do it yourself.
I'm ready to tolerate him as long as he's useful.
He saved me and he helps me as best he can.
I don't know about that.
I don't think he helps me.
What do you mean the best he can?
We don't know anything about this guy.
I'm ready to tolerate him as long as he's useful.
That's the right attitude.
Use him and don't let him sit on your neck.
Because he's already planning how to use you.
The girl, you saved her.
You let her into your room.
You even gave her your bed.
Poor naive boy.
Ashes!
I'm late to stream and the first thing I hear is you finally came.
I feel very called out right now.
Yeah, I mean, welcome.
You still don't even know who she is.
Don't you think she's too friendly?
She's using me.
She's hiding something.
I mean, she is.
She just wants to survive.
That seems to be the case, right?
Of course.
What is she ready to do for this?
Who is she willing to sacrifice?
Look at them.
People like them are everywhere.
They come only when they need something.
And then they leave.
They always leave.
You came here so that this wouldn't happen again.
But they found you even here.
They don't want you.
They want what you are capable of.
I'm the chosen one.
Chosen one!
And you don't need anyone.
Who are you?
Kazoo kid.
Wait a second.
You'll remember.
The important thing is that I'm back and I won't leave you anymore.
Is she like maybe the lady in the photograph?
Maybe it's my mom.
In the photograph.
Take meds?
The meds let me see women!
I'm never taking my meds!
Girls!
Welcome to Babusha!
But it's time for you to leave.
We have a lot of things to do.
Is this why I'm sleeping in the bathroom?
Because I'm...
I'm sleeping in the tub every night.
Day 3 baby!
Superball, thanks for 5 months.
Wait, there is blood now on the floor.
Why is there blood on the floor now?
Kazoo too hard.
Nosebleed?
Wash your face.
No, we just nicked ourselves from shaving.
That's all.
It's just a little scratch, you know?
We're so clumsy.
She's playing some sexy music this morning.
Gosh, I had the greatest dream about a hot girl.
I went and saved her from her room and she was all goth and just so beautiful.
Too bad it was just a dream.
It's a thumbnail.
Oh, hello.
Good morning!
I'm aesthetics.
It's the aesthetic to sleep on the bathroom.
I thought you would sleep on the couch.
I did actually say I was gonna be on the couch.
Lie, lie, stay silent.
Lie, it's safer there.
Wait, so it's not because it's safer in there that I sleep in the bathroom?
That's what I thought it was.
Why is she moving like a robot?
Bebop, Egypt.
Bebop.
Be goth.
I'm human.
I felt sick in the morning.
Now everything is alright.
Okay, then she would think I'm infected.
Which I am, probably, but...
Stay silent?
Or I don't know.
I like how the cups go...
Oh yeah, is this breakfast?
Three Doritos?
Three Doritos chips, an apple, a donut and a banana.
Hot dog!
All the nutritional value.
Why is it a lie though?
I'm gonna try that it's safer there.
Yeah, don't judge me.
What do you mean it didn't turn out very well?
You're acting like you cooked this.
I crafted this breakfast with my own two hands.
I foraged this banana and this apple.
And I fried this donut using the tears of my own soul.
What do you mean?
I will.
I collected all of this, honestly.
She's so quiet compared to the music.
She slaved away to make that meal for you.
I know, I'm a monster.
Thank you for the month, Redoh.
Thank you.
Sounds like we are in someone's nightmare.
Some kind of disease.
It looks like the end of the world.
One word.
Aliens.
So, we do have monsters, but we don't even have one flying saucer.
It's disappointing.
Oh my god, she's so real for this.
So true.
What do you think about the Watcher?
What do you think about that pale monster?
What do you think about that white lady?
What do you think about the Watcher?
Security guy?
I called him yesterday.
He spoke very confidently.
I think we can trust him, but I don't know why he doesn't leave his room.
Suspicious, huh?
Oh, let's eat.
Why did you come to the city?
Tell me honestly, what were you hiding behind the chair?
Where are your parents?
Yeah, what were you hiding behind the chair?
I told you.
Nothing special.
My documents, personal stuff.
It doesn't matter now, but you never know who could come in and...
Then?
The phone is ringing.
You need to answer.
This is probably something important.
Phone is ringing.
I'm gonna... Oh my god.
We can get so close to her.
We can almost see her face.
Does she have blue eyes?
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll get the phone.
But we're not done here, missy.
Pick up the phone.
Hey, how's it going, kid?
Don't bother answering.
I can guess.
I've lost contact with the police and I can't get through to the rescuers.
It seems that due to the riots in the city, some telephone lines have been cut off.
That's a major bummer.
That's an understatement.
Her face is so lewd they had to censor it.
Yeah, I'll call the church right after this.
But I've got a plan.
There's a big antenna on the roof of the hotel.
If we can tweak it, I might be able to radio someone from the rescue team.
But here's the thing.
You're the one who's going to have to climb up there.
Why me and not you?
I need to keep an eye on the cameras.
Anything can go wrong any second.
I need to make sure no one gets hurt.
And if someone does get hurt, what are you going to do about it?
Climb the stairs to the top floor.
There's a restaurant there.
You think she's going to be there?
Our lucky lady?
Our white lady?
There's a restaurant there through which you can get out onto the roof.
Find the antenna and contact me via the local phone.
Don't take the girl with you.
You're making too much noise while you're together.
We're being too goofy silly in the hallways.
We're just like goofy silly girls.
We're just like giggling and you know, we're just like catwalking.
We're strutting down those hallways.
We're being so silly.
I need to look at the cameras so that if something goes wrong, I can send you to deal with it.
Exactly!
This guy is such a coward.
Good luck.
Oh, okay.
Do you need to go upstairs?
Yeah.
Sorry, I heard that part of the call.
Yeah?
You know, I'm not going to just sit on your neck.
I'll go downstairs and see what's going on on the first floor.
Do you need anything in particular?
What does that mean, sit on my neck?
You can?
Please do?
What's wrong with you guys?
You guys are so...
Oh, let's see.
Stay here is not worth the risk.
Look for food and supplies.
Check what the guard is doing there.
Try to find a way to escape.
I don't think we need to leave.
Because...
I think the hotel is probably the safest place to be, honestly.
But, stay here is not worth the risk.
Do we risk sending out our Goth GF?
What if she never comes home?
Check out what the guard is doing there.
I don't know.
I think we ate a donut and three potato chips.
We are going to die at this rate.
I'm going to tell her to stay here though.
What if she dies if she goes downstairs?
I'm going to tell her to stay here.
Stay here.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Fine.
OK.
Cool.
Now let's call...
Whatever this is.
66-112.
And I also want to call this foster place again and see if anything changed.
You know?
If the woman visits, just don't answer the door.
Hello, you've called the church of Jonah's side.
This looks like the symbol from Fullmetal Alchemist.
If you want to learn more about our church, press 1.
If you want to hear a new message for Jonah's followers, press 2.
For information about lost souls... Oh, that's me.
3.
One of our sisters from Nunneva has gone missing.
Her parents, friends, and church brethren miss her and pray for her.
It is the duty of every brother and sister in our friendly community to return the lost sheep to the flock.
Ask your pastor about her features and pass on information about her if you see her.
Aha.
If you want to learn more about our church, press 1.
Let's press 1.
The sign of Jonah teaches us about the benefits of solitude and isolation.
Okay, you're selling it?
Only by isolating ourselves from the world and focusing on self-knowledge can we rise above sin.
We will teach you to accept solitude and become a shining torch that punishes vices.
Do I have to do work?
If you want to hear a message, press 2.
This is the message.
The hour has come, brothers and sisters.
Go out and preach.
The Great Whale has appeared to swallow sinners and bring them to God.
There is only you and him.
Save.
Punish.
Follow the path of the One.
Okay.
Hang up.
Interesting.
And then 662525.
Because remember they said last time, they were like, something happened at your...
At your foster place.
Oh my God, my nose got...
I didn't pick up.
My nose got so stuffy all of a sudden.
Okay, I'll be back later, ma'am.
Oh my God, the little cutouts.
Wow, I like her necklace even.
She is so cute.
God, she is so smoking hot.
How did we get so lucky?
Thank you, woman, for being...
You know what?
Thank you, Apocalypse.
What the hell is going on with this song?
Thank you, Apocalypse, for bringing this beauty upon me.
Urgent news.
Contact with rescue services have been lost and...
This morning I sat and looked out the window...
And I realized...
I'm empty.
It's not a cult.
It's a tight-knit community that cares for each other.
You city slickers don't know what real community is.
Yeah, it's not a cult.
It's not a cult.
I realized I'm empty.
At least for you.
Hello.
I'm a voice in the background.
I deliver news and tell stories that will turn into a dream as soon as you change the channel.
But even these messages are more real to you than I am.
You realize that I exist only when I stammer or mix up my words.
In your eyes, I am the embodiment of a mistake.
Without a body, without life beyond the ether...
A mistake.
Only then do I appear.
The NPC realizes it's an NPC.
It's becoming aware.
Today I will kill a man.
Well, will you notice me now?
You're gonna play the Pink Panther after that?
Alright, time to go to the rooftop, baby.
Oh.
Yeah, Robin?
Thanks, Robin.
Oh.
Lock the door.
Keep it shut.
If I open it back up, will she still be there?
Oh, yep.
She's waiting for me like a little puppy.
Okay.
Alright.
It's a little spooky, but...
You know, we've handled things.
Never ask a white lady her age.
A security guard his...
salary.
Or a goth GF the contents of her mysterious package.
Oh, this guy.
You still in here?
I heard someone wandering along the corridor.
Corridor.
Go back to your room, young man.
Sadly, that is...
not an option for me to...
continue the game.
Oh, it's my...
lady and wife.
Oh, there she goes.
Get it?
I would say lady and wife, but...
I upped our title.
You're the lady and...
I wish we could use the elevator.
So I don't have to walk all the way over.
She's not down here.
Surely I don't have to go through these rooms again, right?
Were these scratch marks here before?
Oh, the bodies are gone.
Well, they're knocked over.
Who did that?
It was such a...
Such a lovely display.
Oh, God.
The texture's loading and it freaked me out.
Is she down here?
Okay, no.
Okay.
The dress is gone.
She's gonna wear it for our date tonight.
Alright, so we're going...
upstairs.
To the rooftop.
That bird's still here.
Okay.
Fourth floor.
And keep on...
Oh?
A squid?
I think I'm hallucinating, you guys.
Guys, I think we're...
Actually, I can't tell what is a hallucination and what is...
What is just normal in this new universe.
What is normal now?
For...
For this place.
Okay, fifth floor.
Ah...
Oh, it's actually really clean up here.
Okay, nice.
Maybe this area hasn't been touched.
Maybe we're fine.
Oh.
Oh, just kidding.
It was wishful thinking.
Yeah, we know it's broken.
Blue's Night.
September 11th, 1993.
The Sanity Inn.
She's waiting for you in our restaurant.
What the hell does that mean?
Squid plus goth girl.
I've seen enough H to know where this is going.
Did you ever figure out the one word you were searching for...
for the emotion you've been feeling recently?
IBS?
Huh?
Is it in there?
Wait, what's in here?
Nothing.
Okay.
The music is so...
loud.
Okay, is there gonna be like a boss fight in here?
What is...
What's with this atmosphere?
I can't see anything.
Oh my god!
It's one of those...
little...
T-Rex guys.
The Google T-Rex.
Okay.
Maybe I'll head towards the light.
Love what you've done with the place.
Oh look, this table's empty.
Is it for us?
Hello, ma'am.
I didn't...
Oh my gosh, there is a female model.
I didn't know we were having...
a head tonight.
Oh, the spaghetti also looks delicious.
Lovely.
This guy has got his Joker costume on.
Hello.
Maybe I can sneak past her.
Nope, I'm stuck.
Maybe...
Oh, this way?
Let's go...
this way.
Rizgum!
Oh my god.
Lucky.
Lucky, lucky.
You guys want a South beer?
A North beer?
A West beer?
Or an East beer?
We got it all here.
We got the American Oak.
We've got the Juniper.
We've got...
the Rose's Gin.
Is that her singing?
It's kind of a vibe.
She's kind of awesome.
She's my dream woman right now.
Okay, we can't do that.
Okay.
I'm gonna try and maybe sneak around her.
I couldn't go that way, so...
maybe if I cut through here?
No?
Okay.
Maybe if I just go really slow, she won't notice me.
Oh my gosh!
White lady!
I didn't see you there.
What?
That's so crazy.
What a coinkidink.
I knew you would come.
Let's go.
I've booked us a table.
Oh.
Awesome.
How did you get up here so fast?
This one for us?
Okay.
You're late.
But I forgive you.
She likes me a lot, I think.
I didn't go on a date with you.
That sounds...
She said sand, so the beach.
Right?
We went to the beach.
The sea.
The sunset.
And just the two of us.
The proposal.
It was in the restaurant.
Here.
You didn't have to serve my favorite!
I love a bratwurst.
I love that.
Thank you.
I didn't know you.
Wait, what?
I proposed?
Wait, someone proposed to you?
But they didn't even know who you were?
Doubts.
Then you raised a glass and made a toast.
Your words then.
Repeat them.
To love.
To you.
To trust.
I can't drink.
Your beauty has made my head spin more than champagne.
To love sounds like she would...
Like, I don't want to just spend all my gum.
What if we need it later?
To love.
I would like to believe that.
You said I was the only one for you.
I quit my job.
For you.
I left my loved ones.
Oh god.
And you left.
But I'm here.
Took away my family.
Friends.
Youth.
Nothing is left.
Nothing.
I don't understand what you're talking about.
Please.
He treated you terribly.
But I came back.
I will be with you.
Do we really play into her Delulu?
Number two, he treated you terribly.
It might be good, right?
Oh yeah.
You...
You're not him, right?
Yeah, I'm different.
I'm not like them.
She doesn't...
It went down.
You should leave.
Leave.
Get out!
No.
Don't look at me.
Leave.
Leave!
She's gone.
Just like that.
It's my show now.
Why am I so tiny?
I would like to dedicate this one to all the lonely fellas out there.
If it hadn't been for Cotton Eye Joe.
I've been married a long time ago.
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
Thank you.
Date night is looking good for everybody.
I can't see anything.
I don't know if there's anything to grab here.
I don't feel like searching the darkness.
Alright.
To the rooftop!
Rooftop!
To the toilet.
Nevermind.
I need to use the restroom after that encounter we had.
Because I want to pee my pants.
Well, no.
I was going to.
I don't want to.
Wait.
What's out here?
Or over here, I mean.
Okay, nevermind.
I don't want to go into the darkness.
I
was going to pee my pants, but then I said I want to go to the bathroom.
So I just combined it!
I didn't mean to say that!
I didn't mean to say...I messed up.
I messed it up!
You know what I meant, I think.
Stop sending a blues!
I hear a phone ringing.
I thought from far away it said Minty Island.
Oh yeah!
DJ Donald!
Marisha!
And Scott Boys!
Party Island, Friday 24th of April!
Do you know what day it is tomorrow?
Yeah, it's Party Island!
Sleepy Mint sure says some special things.
I'm picking up...
The government lies.
They are already here.
Mind control.
Do you hear voices?
They are not hallucinations.
Experiments on humans.
Mutagens in the water.
Super slaves and super soldiers.
Find out the truth.
Oh, the little...
He even decorated the backside.
That's so exciting.
Is this guy like...
Did he do all of...
Oh wait!
Didn't we...
We went to a room that had the map and everything.
So he is part of the government lies.
Alright, let's go to the...
This is crazy that we are outside.
There are so many birds!
Why are there so many birds?
Where are they going?
Is it up here?
Oh yeah.
Wait, hold on.
Before that, is there anything over here?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Oh, I can see downstairs!
Wait, that's so awesome!
It's pretty bad looking.
I'm not gonna lie.
Who are the patriots?
Can you jump?
You cannot jump.
City looks pretty rough, yeah.
City looks pretty rough.
This has been pretty solid for an indie horror game, you know.
Indie horror games are always hit and miss.
Thanks to you and Doki, I went to Costco and bought some stuff.
Boom!
Then I bought dinner because I was waiting for a car fix until I saw a double chunk chocolate chip cookie.
Brain rot.
Hey, you took so long to answer that I thought you were done for.
Oh, I met the white lady.
It's amazing that you managed to get here at all.
I saw on the cameras what she does to people she meets and it's an unpleasant sight.
It seems that you have your own personal guardian angel.
To send a distress signal, you need to adjust to turn and turn on this old antenna.
Zaib, thank you so much for the 10 gift.
It looks complicated but it's simple.
Just listen to me carefully.
There should be a panel with switches to your right.
This thing regulates the voltage of the antenna.
Set it so that it shows 10...
Oh, volts.
10 volts.
That should be enough.
Oh, we're still on the phone.
So it needs to be 10?
And is that 12?
There we go.
Math.
Great.
I started hearing interference on the radio.
Which means the signal went out.
We need to set the transmission frequency.
To the left, there should be a panel with a green screen.
And next to it is a mini antenna for receiving short frequencies.
Turn it so that the signal on the panel matches the amplitude we need.
Okay.
Turn the antenna.
Oh, okay.
Rotate right.
Rotate right again.
Oh, it's getting bigger.
Never mind.
Rotate left.
Rotate right.
Easy.
Well done, kid.
The signal has become clearer.
Now let's launch the large antenna at full power.
In the center, slightly to the right of the phone, there should be a lever.
Oh, I see it.
Pull it and everything will work.
Pull the lever.
I don't think that's how that works, but neat.
It worked!
You did a great job, kid!
When will the answer come?
How is he supposed to know that?
Do I need to do anything else?
No, kid.
You did a great job.
As soon as I can reconfigure the antenna to transmit the signal, the rescuers will come.
But it's a long process.
You will have to wait a couple of days.
All that on only 10 volts?
Don't worry about it.
Maybe it says 10, but it means like 10 million.
Drops into the pit.
Wrong lever!
Go down to your place and wait for my call.
As soon as I can... Oh my god.
So sorry guys, I can't stop yawning.
As soon as I can send a signal, I'll let you know.
Just be careful.
A few minutes ago I noticed movement on your floor.
Oh, wait, where am I?
Am I at my floor?
What's going on?
Gosh, that scared me.
The lady!
That's so freaky!
Oh my god!
Oh, there's a raid?
Thank you for the raid!
Hello, hello!
It's a bit of a spooky game.
Oh...
Oh my god.
This way.
Wait, I'm possessed though.
I don't know, I didn't see who raided me, but thank you!
Raymac, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Am I going back to my room when I'm possessed?
Is that a good idea?
Murphy, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Gosh, the stuff loading in really freaks me out sometimes.
See, like that.
Hey, you okay in there?
Guess we can't knock.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Oh my god!
I was waiting for you.
Oh my gosh, priest, you scared me!
Let's go.
I want to talk to you.
To my room.
I said, come with me.
Yes sir.
Yes?
In here?
Wait, were you the guy in here the whole time?
I'm so small.
I'm like, hey mister, were you the guy in here?
Were you the man that I helped out earlier?
Okay, I'm in here.
I'm in here.
Wait, he didn't kill the guy in here, right?
Where is he?
I want to apologize for our previous meeting.
I've done you wrong.
I succumbed to empty suspicions and would like to ask for your forgiveness.
Oh, maybe he's not a bad guy.
Do you accept my apologies?
Where is the room owner?
Don't get distracted by trifles.
Focus on our conversation.
I have prepared something for you.
A gift.
Okay, I like that.
And a lesson.
Oh, I have to learn?
I always apologize with gun in hand.
True.
No!
He's in the closet!
Not like that, but...
Beep beep!
6 out of 10 gifted!
What's happening?
A confession.
I learned a lot from our last meeting.
Hard days have come.
The end of times.
I will teach you how to get through it.
The man living in this room is sinful.
He confessed it himself.
This sin eats him from the inside, turns him into a spawn of hell.
Accept his confession and I will pass judgment.
You have time.
Wait, what?
Not too much time.
Are you alive?
Please don't do that!
Wait, young man, is that you?
He burst in here with a gun.
He said I was infected and threatened to kill me.
Oh my god, the timer.
I'm healthy.
Please convince him to leave.
Are you experiencing any strange symptoms?
Symptoms?
My nosebleed won't stop.
And I can't sleep because of nightmares.
But that doesn't mean anything.
Why are you bleeding?
He gives us time.
I have a high blood pressure.
It happens when I'm nervous.
I don't want to ask about the nightmares.
It might incriminate him.
Do you have any proof that you're sick?
You helped me with the medicines.
There should be an empty bottle somewhere in the room.
Also, my pressure gauge is somewhere here.
Okay, talk about something else.
We'll attack him.
Tell me what happened.
The medicine you found has run out.
I went to find a first aid kit but ran into this madman in the corridor.
He shoved me into the closet so I couldn't run away and interrogated me.
Everything will be fine.
Don't waste your time.
I'll be back soon.
Wait, something about his sin, right?
Okay, so look under the bed.
Take the medicine.
Label says it helps cope with high blood pressure.
I'm coping?
Okay, nice.
And then he said...
He said his pressure thing, right?
Oh, open?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Pressure gauge.
A device for measuring pressure.
It will help prove that this poor guy is sick but not infected.
Okay, are you alive?
I found an empty medicine bottle.
This is my blood pressure medicine.
It will confirm that my bleeding is indeed due to illness.
He said something about your sin?
I feel guilty, yes, towards my son, but I don't want to talk about it.
Interesting, okay.
And it shouldn't matter.
He's not telling the whole truth about his son.
I need to search the room.
Okay, I'll be back.
I don't think we should attack him.
I don't think we should attack that guy.
Anything in here?
Your son in here?
Faded photograph.
Photograph of a mother and child, but there's no father in them.
I mean, there might be.
The dog!
Reminds me of my childhood photos.
It seems the neighbor did not participate in the family life.
I mean, there is a father.
He's just crossed out.
But also the dog!
So funny.
Okay, I think we can talk to him now.
Speak.
I can prove that he doesn't deserve to die.
Are you sure?
If not, it will only make things worse.
Yes.
The time has come.
It's time to pass judgment.
What do you think?
Does he bear the devil's mark?
Did my stream go down?
Oh, did YouTube...
Did YouTube...
Oh, we're back?
Sorry.
I think something happened with YouTube.
A little hiccup.
After this, I'm gonna get more water.
He's not infected.
He's sick with something.
It could be anything.
We're just making it worse.
I don't know.
You think so?
Then tell me.
Why is he bleeding?
He has high blood pressure.
Pressure.
It causes nosebleed.
Do you have proof?
Or do you just want to believe it?
I found his blood pressure medicine.
Alright, let's say I believe you.
He said he is tormented by nightmares.
You heard the radio messages, my son.
You know what this means.
He's worried about his family.
His dreams are only about them.
Oh, maybe I should have asked about the nightmares.
No one spoke to him in his dreams.
Look at what's happening around us.
He's just scared.
Do you believe the radio?
Should we trust it?
The devil sends him nightmares.
No, we know he's worried about his family.
His son.
What difference does it make who he dreams of?
Nightmares have already captured him.
One way or another, he admitted the guilt himself.
Although he didn't say what he's guilty of.
Did you find that out?
People will say anything at gunpoint.
When he was young, he abandoned his family and his little son.
The Bible says, judge not that ye...
Wait, judge not that ye be not judged.
I don't know.
Did he abandon his family?
I thought he said like he gave a lot of money to his son.
Right?
The picture.
Oh, it did say that.
Oh, yeah, I guess like...
Don't pick three.
This one?
Is that bad?
What does that mean?
Judge not that ye be not judged.
Is it double negative?
I don't understand it.
Don't judge people.
Oh, three is preachy.
Oh, he's a preacher.
Oh, he's a priest.
I'll try two.
Betrayal is the worst of sins.
What do you think he deserves?
Oh, betrayal.
Is that really the worst of sins?
Maybe murder is what...
I think murder might be up there too, Mr. Priest.
The choice has been made and the sentence has been passed, my son.
Still absolutely shooket by how amazing your 3.0 looks.
Thank you!
Yeah, I love it so much too.
I'm glad you like it.
Oh, innocent!
You convinced the priest to spare your neighbor.
I forgive those sins that torment him.
You're welcome.
For what?
For this lesson.
Do not trust even those who seem innocent.
In the world of sin, only sinners are found.
Now go.
Until we meet again.
You're going to let him out though, right?
Are you alive?
Is he letting me go?
Thank god!
Thank you!
I won't come out of here until he leaves.
See you later.
You can't come out of here.
He literally...
Wait, wait, wait.
Downtown bombing.
Oh my god.
But you can't get out.
He put the chair...
You're going to move the chair though, right?
You're going to move the chair, Mr. Priest?
Oh my god, we almost saw his face for a second.
Don't tilt your head at me like that.
OK, I'm getting out of here.
OK.
Let's just go home.
Oh my god.
Why does it sound like that?
Oh my god, it was so...
I thought I was going to hear a gunshot after.
Hello, I'm home!
God, you scared me!
I did!
I fixed the antenna!
I met a priest.
He threatened our neighbor.
It's already over.
Don't worry.
Should I be honest?
I met a priest.
Did he threaten the neighbor?
Yeah.
OK, she definitely came from that cult.
She definitely came from that cult.
She also needs to know that the priest is dangerous, right?
Are you sure?
OK.
I'm just going to take a little nap.
Hopefully I don't go to the ocean.
You know?
Just a nap in the inn.
The nap in my hotel room.
The nap...
Why am I in the bathroom again?
Is this happening?
Is this real?
Do I need to censor?
Wait.
Isn't it dangerous there?
There is where?
Where are we going?
Trust me.
We're leaving?
This has to be a dream.
Oh my god.
She just left so casually.
There is no way this is real.
I don't see any water.
And the moon is back to normal actually.
No, there is no way this is real.
Skinny dipping?
Don't, don't.
Wait, what is she doing?
Oh my god, we are vandalizing the place.
Let's go!
It doesn't look great.
It looks cute.
Why did you do this?
You are drawing attention towards us.
No, it looks cute.
It's a little lopsided.
I don't think you tried hard enough, Robin.
Oh, hell yeah.
Okay, pick up a spray paint.
Cold to the touch.
It was used often.
Dang, she's... Oh my god, she's a bad girl.
We're drawing?
Oh, okay.
What should I draw?
Whatever you want.
Let's make this place more lively.
Just think of something and write it.
Oh yeah, I was really getting sick of the blood decor, you know.
She's a baddie for real.
Or just draw without thinking.
Let's see what happens.
I wonder if it will let me draw whatever I want.
Draw without thinking.
Write hopeless.
Write what happens now.
Write stay alive.
Close your eyes and draw without thinking.
You know what?
I wanna see what comes out of my brain.
Oh my gosh, it's probably gonna be like a peepee, but...
Okay,
now it's my turn.
What are you gonna draw?
Looks like the type of woman that would make you worse mentally.
Maybe.
I love her little hair ribbons, they're so cute.
No tongue?
She hates the French.
No tongue, I don't understand what it means.
You can't speak frankly?
We should stay quiet?
I don't understand what this means.
She is so weird.
Robin, are you okay?
This is really, all of this is really getting to her head, I think.
What does that have to do with tongue?
I'm riding, I hate my past.
Oh gosh, what are we gonna write now?
Remember the foster care and write alone.
She's just a little freaky.
No tongue kissing?
She's tired of tongues.
Gyutan, remember your mother and write rip.
Remember why I came to the hotel.
She's not a cunning linguist.
She hates tongue.
Draw without thinking, should I draw without thinking again?
Am I gonna write more eldritch horror stuff?
Oh gosh, I don't know.
Rip, no tongue, maybe I should say rip because it's just like...
Oh, no tongue, rip.
Four again?
You guys want four again?
Three or four?
Three maybe.
Oh, but why I came to the hotel.
Yeah, we still don't really exactly know why I'm here.
It still hasn't really been explained yet.
Okay, let's try three.
No future.
No future, no tongue.
Why I came to the hotel.
Yeah.
So true.
Robin is such an optimist, I love her.
She's definitely not very gothy.
Nice handwriting though.
I know, we have like the perfect graffiti handwriting.
What do you want to ask me, Robin?
What do you mean by... I thought she was gonna confess her love to me.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh my gosh, we really are in the video game.
Wait, she knows that I'm...
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I have...
I can't distinguish faces and intonations.
I can't distinguish faces and intonations except your voice.
I just like to think a lot.
Oh, the fourth wall shattered.
Oh my god.
That's why we can't see the faces.
I have...
Oh, agnosia.
Number two, to risk her up.
Oh yeah, let's do that.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, you're giving up to me?
Alien.
I want to see what her alien looks like.
Okay, do it.
Oh, here we go.
Let's go.
Let's see the alien.
Alien?
Appreciated, but not accepted.
Yeah, I think so too.
Bold and brash.
It really does look like that Squidward picture.
Aww, I did have fun.
Okay guys, I'm gonna go grab more water real quick and I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
So I will be back in like just a few...
In like just a minute.
Maybe I should get coffee instead of water.
I'm gonna grab something with caffeine.
I'm gonna grab something with caffeine instead.
Go pee your pants, girl.
I'm gonna go pee my pants!
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I said hello to my kitties as well.
My paws, my girl cat.
She's been slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly warming up to me.
But recently more, she's been sleeping at my feet.
So I'm happy about that.
And I went to go check on her and she was in my bed.
So I was happy about that.
Which she does not lay in my bed often.
So I was like, yay!
And she'll like sleep at my feet.
Which I hate, typically.
Oh my gosh, I hate a lot.
I hate when cats sleep at my feet.
And Butaro, he sleeps by my head.
So it's so much nicer.
But she'll sleep at my feet.
But he'll, he's gotten like a little...
How do I say?
He's become a little bit...
I don't think it's greedy is the right word.
But he'll like go up to her and demand to be licked.
And then if she doesn't lick him...
Well, she'll lick him and then he'll like attack her.
And then they'll start fighting at my feet.
And I'm like, can you not do that?
Can you not fight at my feet, please?
No tongue in Russian is the beginning of some...
Oh, I missed it.
No!
Wait, so it has meaning?
I feel like this game is not first language English.
Just from some of the ways they talk a little bit, but...
But...
It was definitely originally Russian.
Oh, I see.
It's a Russian team.
I see, I see, I see.
Yeah, so...
Wait, hold on.
Let me read what that said.
Translates to there is no tongue or language where their voice isn't heard.
Matara is a translator.
Oh my gosh, I'm seeing her next week.
Unfortunately, she's like staying at my house.
Alright, let's continue.
Alright, we're just walking back.
No tongue, baby.
No tongue, no future.
A heart.
Alright, back to sleep.
Alright, good night.
Naino, happy birthday!
This helped me a lot in this era of asking for a PS3 with MGS4.
And pen lights for the upcoming concert.
Oh my gosh!
Happy birthday!
Wait, it won't let me shut the door.
Okay, hold on.
She's waiting for me.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Naino.
Happy birthday!
Okay, good night.
Thanks for going with me.
Of course.
I thought this would help you relax.
But it looks like it was important for me too.
You feel better now?
Okay, it's getting late.
Let's take a rest.
Yeah.
I have a feeling that the next few days will not be easy.
I mean, I hope a little bit.
I'm in confessional?
Forgive me father for I have sinned.
I know about it my son.
Tell me what happened.
It's been a long day.
A lot has happened.
I just tortured out how to super...
Yeah, thank you.
Let's talk about the meeting at the restaurant first.
About that woman.
You could have pretended to be her husband.
But you decided to ruin everything.
No!
You destroyed her beautiful dream because of your own needs.
Was it worth it?
She had to know the truth.
She was calmer when she had her fantasies.
What are you talking about?
She became a monster.
Are you the one controlling her?
You destroyed her beautiful dream.
Do I be suspicious of them right away?
I'm torn between 1 and 4.
One for sure?
Wait, hold on.
I'm sorry.
I missed the super chat.
Forgive me father.
I have sinned by giving money to Minto.
Thank you Drezik.
You have been forgiven of all your sins.
Too early for 4?
Okay, we'll go with 1.
She had to know the truth.
Truth is a sad dream that always ends in death.
You'll understand this only when it's too late.
Did we save that woman then?
Somehow.
The man next door, you participated in his interrogation.
You convinced the priest to leave him alive.
A commendable but empty aspiration.
This man will continue to use you, but won't help you in any way.
Why did the priest want to kill him?
How do you know?
Did you order him to do this?
What's happening with the priest?
I don't like any of these options.
Yeah, the guy gave us food.
That's so true.
Yeah, what's happening with the priest?
He hurts someone who can be trusted without doubts.
His lord.
He's happy in his zeal.
That's not all.
You've let this girl manipulate you again.
It's a pity.
She woke you up in the middle of the night.
Put you at risk for her own desires.
Don't worry.
You were under my protection.
This time.
What do you mean your protection?
You need to draw some conclusions.
What do you think... What did you think about today?
I did what I could.
I made some mistakes.
I'm not going to answer you.
Why are you so interested in me?
I don't think I made any mistakes.
I think I did everything perfectly well.
Do you like me voice?
Why do you like me?
Why are you so interested?
Any preacher knows.
Once you understand how to reach the most stubborn soul.
You'll understand how to get into the hearts of everyone else.
Because I'm so stubborn.
Because I'm not...
Wait.
Is this... I can't tell.
Is the infection like...
Sentient?
You think?
Maybe the infection is sentient.
And is like...
Trying to figure out how to take over control of me because I'm so stubborn.
And then... If they know how to take control of me, they'll be like...
I can apply that to anybody else who I haven't taken control of.
Lovecraftian?
It's time to end this conversation.
Good morning.
Good morning!
Can I leave?
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
My space lady!
Gosh, I have so many ladies.
I got goth lady.
I got white lady.
I got space lady.
Why am I so tiny?
I've gotten tinier.
Thank you for opening up to me.
I feel that we've become closer.
There are almost no barriers left.
Really?
I feel like we have quite a few barriers.
Leave me alone!
Is that why you come to me?
What are you doing to us?
I don't want to get on her bad side though.
Is she the infection?
I feel like we're starting to really not trust her though.
What is...OK.
A ghost man never makes any mistakes.
They teehee!
Precisely when they mean to.
Teehee!
What are you doing to us?
The confession is over.
Go.
You have difficult days ahead of you.
No!
Selection.
What does that mean?
Oh, day 7.
You have survived until the beginning of the 7th day.
Good morning.
You know, just infected people things.
Don't worry about it.
I think we have enough for a couple more days.
Could you check on the water in the bathroom?
Yesterday it almost dried out.
We should try to collect it in something just in case.
In my mouth.
I hate this channel.
This one sucks.
Oh, let's listen to the news.
Did they kill a person?
I am a voice.
I voice.
I voice, I voice, I voice, voice, voice, voice.
I am voice.
OK, voice is really starting to look like not a word right now.
Anything more upbeat?
OK, whatever.
We gotta check on the water.
I am voice, voice, voice, voice.
Oh no.
No, there is no water.
Let's look for bottles of water.
OK.
Alright, we'll call the watcher.
Yeah, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, we also have another pamphlet to call.
Oh wait, this one doesn't have a number.
But this one, the government lies.
Hold on, I'm turning this off real quick.
Goodbye.
Pick up the phone.
Hold on, we want to call the government.
6-6.
3-1-4 Oh yeah, baby.
Hello, government.
Who is this?
Are you one of them?
Yes.
So, the world government has finally found me.
I knew this would happen.
I will still tell everyone the truth about what is really happening.
What truth?
About what's happening on the streets.
You understand what this means, right?
Hey, I turned that off.
The world government doesn't need those who can think.
They only need slaves and soldiers.
Oh my gosh, it's Mother Base.
Some will work on building the new order, while others will destroy all opposition.
They don't even need us all.
A billion or even less will suffice.
That's why the massacre began.
Is this One Piece?
Is this what One Piece is about?
Only the most loyal and strong will remain.
How do they do it?
Water!
It's all in the water, buddy.
That's what we need.
They add chemicals to it.
A wild mix of psychotropic substances and mutagens.
They make you see what you want while they mold your body into what they want.
But I know how to get around it.
No water!
Only coffee.
Lots of coffee!
And vodka.
Maybe he is on to something.
The world government?
Banks, corporations, fast food chains, garbage collectors.
Even the garbage collectors.
They are all part of the world government.
It's Russian.
All because he said vodka?
They hid aliens, conducted experiments on US citizens.
They pretended that the USSR had collapsed.
But I know the truth.
All of this was just a preparation for what is happening now.
I think I shouldn't have called.
Many people prefer to close their eyes after learning the truth.
They imagine that all of this doesn't exist.
That it's all a fiction.
They laughed at me when I tried to tell them.
Who is laughing now?
No one, because they are all dead.
I'm so lonely.
Someone is knocking on the hatch.
I've been found.
They probably tapped the phone.
It's OK.
I won't give up without a fight.
Meet my double barrel, you Illuminati bitches!
He really did... I thought we were going to learn about aliens.
What about the aliens?
Oh man, they got him.
OK.
Oh yeah, I was calling the watcher.
Uh...
Oh, 007.
Security post, how can I help?
We are out of water in our room.
You know, you are the only guest who always got something to complain about.
Monsters in the hallway, no water.
You are a terrible client.
I hate this guy.
But then again, the other guests are either dead or insane.
So there is not much of a comparison.
Are you joking about this?
Are you joking?
I'm literally about to die of dehydration and you are joking?
I can only eat so many donuts.
So what's up again?
Uh, we are out of water?
Ah, right.
Looks like the emergency pump has failed.
It needs to be restarted.
I'm going to have to be the one to do it all.
Come down to me on the first floor.
Find the security room.
It's behind the reception desk.
I'll guide you from there.
Wait, he's going to lead me?
This will be my first time meeting him.
Interesting.
Why don't you fix the pump yourself?
Yeah, why doesn't this guy do anything?
Because...
I'm busy.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to establish communication.
This is a much more important task for all of us.
See you later.
He hung up.
What a coward.
We need to go downstairs.
Aren't we?
He annoys me so much.
Is he going to turn on us, I think?
He's like doing something secretive to...
To...
I don't know.
He's...
He's the one who shut off the water.
We haven't been out for a long time.
I don't even know what's going on there now.
You, thirsty for water.
Him, thirsty for sick burns.
No, her, thirsty for water.
Us, thirsty for goth girl.
Tell you what.
I'll go out first and open the door to the stairs for you.
You'll wait a little and follow.
Oh, okay.
Wait, yeah, we've been in our room for a couple days.
We went from like day 3 to day 7 or something.
Let's stay separate.
This way there will be less chance of being noticed.
Okay, that works for me.
Where will you go?
I'll check the first floor.
Maybe I can snag something from the vending machines.
Yeah, okay, nice.
Okay, I'll go out first and you'll follow.
Walk towards the stairs.
Good luck.
Okay, I wish we could turn off the radio.
It's so...
Why can't this turn on?
Maybe...
Like, it's so annoying because it's so loud.
Now, turn off.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
I'm heading to the stairs.
Oh, our graffiti.
What the hell was that?
Oh, the light.
Oh my god.
Oh...
She's so brave.
You really are like Raiden.
The way the washer keeps bossing you around.
Young man, do you have a minute?
I'd like to talk to you.
What else should I do?
Sure.
I'm working on a theory of infection.
But there are some inconsistencies.
I need an outside opinion.
Okay.
The first question is about the variety of physical changes in the victims.
You've encountered these unfortunate people much more than I have.
How does this guy have enough food?
What do you think influences their differences?
The amount of infection affects them?
They depend on personality and experiences?
The changes seem random.
I don't know.
I don't think it's a personality and experience.
Maybe it's the amount of the affection.
Because the lady would change.
But she wasn't fully infected.
And then that...
The bald guy seemed completely infected.
And he was like an actual monster.
Right?
We don't know, Minto.
This is me theorizing.
Three?
You think it's three?
I think it's per individual.
Each person is a way different monster.
I think it's four though.
I think it's four.
Like I said, I think it's...
I don't know.
But I guess it does... I don't know if it's personality based.
I think it's how much the affection...
Right?
I don't know.
Okay, everybody is saying three.
I'll do three.
Alright, next question.
One of the first signs of changes is nightmares.
As I understand it, their essence varies depending on the victim's experience.
But is there something common in them?
Isn't this gonna just...
Isn't this gonna rat us out?
How do we know it's water though?
Those are just our nightmares.
I'm gonna say how should I know.
I see.
Alright.
Now let's talk about the level of physical changes.
How noticeable are they?
People turn into monsters!
Let's just say, quite noticeable.
I barely notice a difference.
People are turning into monsters, Mr. Neighbor.
Is that so?
Curious.
Alright, I'm ready to draw a conclusion.
Okay, we're really doing the scientific method here.
We call this condition an infection.
It seems that it's not quite right.
We are observing an impossible manifestation of psychosomatics.
The psychological state generates changes in the body.
The laws of our universe do not allow such changes.
Whatever caused them, it came from outside.
Aliens!
I'm talking about a dimension with completely different rules.
About a place where thought is as real as a physical object.
I don't have enough data to say more.
Thank you for helping me understand this issue a bit better, young man.
Aliens.
Alright, so far so good, I suppose.
Wait, there's someone in here?
And the priest got her?
I think this is the symbol of the priest, right?
But she's still alive.
So I guess she's fine.
Hello, are you okay in there?
Okay.
Well...
So much for that, I think.
Gosh, that's a lot of blood.
Oh, he's been going around on everybody.
Look, he's been covering them up.
This guy has like total control of this hallway.
Oh my god.
Look, this door too.
There was somebody in here also.
And this one too.
Oh my god.
This guy is just taking control of everything.
Maybe he's infected.
I don't know.
Time to go downstairs?
Here we go.
What's that sound?
Motorcycle?
Or a helicopter?
Second floor.
Third floor.
Can we go to this floor?
No.
It looks like I don't want to go there anyway.
Oh shit.
Maybe that's what we heard.
It just saved.
Do you think I can go downstairs?
Maybe he'll walk away.
Mary, thanks for the five gifted.
I don't think that's friend.
I need to distract him.
I'll try to throw something down the stairs.
I just had to get closer.
We can take that.
Is there anything else we can take?
Nevermind.
I'll take this.
And...
Push.
Oh my god, he's looking right at me.
I think he noticed me.
I have to let go when he's not sensing.
I'll do it after the next one.
I think we're good.
Oh my god, I opened it so slowly.
I opened it so quietly.
Good job, guy.
Good job.
They're on the first floor now?
Okay, I think we're safe.
I can barely see anything outside.
The note.
He likes to call himself the Watcher.
This guy is such a weirdo.
He says it's not just a job.
He has the same call sign back in the army.
And he calls me a slug.
What?
He thinks I can't hear it.
Why is he always so silent?
Jerk.
Go there.
Do this.
I know why you don't do anything yourself.
Wheel-legged?
That's why he can't help.
He's just doing his best.
Oh no.
He's probably like...
Yeah, he probably has no legs from the war or something.
Oh my gosh.
Where is our girlfriend?
Goth GF, where are you?
I'm scared.
What if a monster notices me from the windows?
This is our first time on the first floor, so...
What's that sound?
Oh gosh, there's new monsters down here.
Anything over here?
Any gum?
Any Riz Gum?
Kariz Gum?
That would be a great brand, right?
This is how it feels to chew Riz Gum.
Okay.
Alright, let's just go towards the spooky noises I guess.
Sounds like an awesome plan.
There's actually no blood down here.
Who said shh?
That was creepy.
Can we go to the pool?
Nope.
Okay, let's go to the security guard.
I saw something.
Yeah, rip the monitors.
I thought I just heard something open up.
Oh my god.
Hello?
It's me.
Can I come in?
No, sorry.
I...
I barricaded myself in here and it won't be quick to open.
But I'm glad to hear your voice in person.
I think we could have done this over the phone.
Could we not?
Because like...
Now I'm like talking very loudly in the wide open.
What are you hiding in there?
I'm not hiding anything.
He's hiding himself.
And if I am, it's none of your business.
You need to go to the swimming pool wing.
Go into the main hall and turn right to the elevator.
To the left of it you'll see an entrance to the pool.
Go there.
You'll need to find the boiler room and restart the pump.
How do I start it?
The staff left instructions in the boiler room.
You can handle it.
Just be careful.
There are no cameras in the pool so I won't be able to help you.
Also lately I've been hearing some kind of rumble from there.
I don't know what it is.
Gosh.
Good luck kid.
Oh no.
I don't like that.
What kind of rumble?
What kind of monster are we gonna face?
No, please.
Oh my god.
Swim trunks.
Actually, let's keep this open.
Anything behind here?
Anything to take?
I'm looting.
Actually, there hasn't been much in this game to loot, huh?
Looks like you could use a hand.
Let's go to the women's bathroom.
We can't.
Just kidding.
Let's go to the men's bathroom.
Nevermind.
Let's...
Are you kidding?
Wait, what was that?
Oh, read the note.
Why is he lucky enough to be so good looking and not me?
Why does he have such a good figure and I don't?
Sure, he can be proud of himself.
I know his secret.
I know what he's taking.
Drop?
Why?
Who wrote this?
Who wrote this and left it in the swimming pool area?
There might be gum in the bathroom.
It won't let me go in there.
We have to go this way.
This is the only way we can go.
But flashing lights warning, I guess, because it's kind of...
I'm checking to see if there's anything.
Okay, no.
Okay.
Yeah, I see.
Alright, here we go.
Into the men's bathroom.
Oh my god, it's so dark.
Oh god.
It's so dark in here.
Gum!
Yes!
Alright, we'll use it next time.
Any gum in the stall?
Okay, that won't open.
Alright.
It's so spooky.
Okay.
The atmosphere in this game is pretty good.
Oh god.
Ew!
Poor...
Poor schmuck died in the shower.
Okay.
This way?
Oh my gosh, at least the flamingo floaty is fine.
What is this?
Oh, it's a slipper.
I was gonna say, what body part is this?
Oh my god, this guy died in like an epic way.
Okay, we have to go all the way around.
Maybe?
Can we go into the women's?
Oh my god, how many people died in here?
For it to be so...
So goopy.
It's so gross.
Okay, can't go in there.
Good soup.
It's like literal jam, jello up in here.
Look at that.
The consistency.
Oh, and it's...
Ew!
Wait, is it warm?
Is that steam?
I can't tell.
Ew, nasty.
Okay.
Pool depth, pool depth.
What's over here?
Oh gosh, wait, there's different pumps?
Oh no.
What's that sound?
Um, I think the monster's...
Taking a leak.
Let's go over down here.
Which pump do you need?
I don't know, it said there would be instructions.
I think if we probably go inside one, it will...
I can't see anything.
It will probably...
Oh my god, that injures me.
Wait, can I not go down here?
I'm running?
Okay.
I don't think there's a way to crouch.
No.
Control or C doesn't do anything.
Oh, we made it to the women's bathroom everybody.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared of this part.
I don't like it at all.
I don't like it, I don't like it.
I don't like it.
It's really freaking me out.
Oh.
It was just like, no peeking.
Okay.
Am I supposed to follow the sound of the...
Oh, that's why we couldn't come in.
Is there anything in here?
There were arrows, yeah, see?
I can't see anything though.
I literally can't see anything.
Settings.
Graphics.
Gamma.
Sorry guys, I'm turning it up a little bit more.
Oh, that didn't do shit.
It literally didn't do anything.
Okay.
Let's go to an area where we can see.
Oh god.
Let's go to an area where the lights are on.
And functional.
Time to use the thermal goggles.
No, I have no... Oh wait, sorry.
I think I turned it down a little bit.
Too much.
Maybe that's better.
Okay, so we know...
We're just gonna ignore that?
What was it?
Okay, don't go in there yet.
Let's go into the...
I don't know.
There's this door too.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's too scary.
It's so scary, you guys!
Oh, I think this is where we need to be.
Okay.
I'm brave, I'm brave.
25 bar, 30 bar, 5 bar, 20 bar.
Oh, this is not where we need to be?
What does this mean?
This is like the longest tubing ever.
Okay, let's go into the other area.
Does not feel up to code.
No, not at all.
At least the flamingo is fine.
The bar is pressure.
Okay, okay.
That doesn't sound good.
Where did my goth GF go?
Sorry for flashing lights.
Oh, we can't go in there.
Oh, down here.
Okay.
This place looks like my screensaver from 1999.
Alright, this seems to be the instructions.
Nevermind.
I was scolded for falling asleep in the boiler room.
Why don't they understand?
It's dark there and no one sees you.
Water drops bring me good dreams.
Valid, but also that doesn't help me.
Rotate.
There's only three, but there were so many bars.
There were so many that said bar.
It's supposed to be a water pressure.
There are other rooms?
Yeah, but they were really dark.
Dark and I'm scared.
I'm scared of going in there.
Follow the specific blue pipe.
Okay.
Alright, everybody follow this pipe.
This one?
Okay, it curves.
And it goes upwards and it goes this way.
Then it goes down and around.
And up and over.
And that way and this way and over.
This seems really unnecessary.
You had a straight path.
This way and down this way.
And over.
And it's 20!
20 is our pipe.
Okay, let's go put 20 on...
that one.
Sorry, I know I don't run a lot in this game.
I'm just afraid of something jumping out at me.
I hope you guys understand.
Alright, 20, 20, 20, 2-0-20.
20.
Okay.
Alright, blue, 20.
Rotate right.
Video games will make you believe you have to traverse sewers almost every day in your life.
I've only done so once per decade.
You're not making the most of your life then.
Who designed this room?
A screensaver?
That yellow pipe.
Okay, 20.
Alright, wait.
Alright, we're good.
For that, I guess.
Probably.
There's no instructions.
Alright, do we go to the other rooms then?
Gosh, it's so...
flashy.
Are we gonna have other rooms like this as well?
Where we have to follow the pipe and...
Gosh, please don't jump out at me.
Please.
Why is it so dark in here?
No way.
Guys, I can't see anything.
Oh.
Wow.
At least...
they don't discriminate.
They're just like, I wanna look sexy.
I wanna look sexy as a man, as a woman, it doesn't matter.
As long as I'm hot.
Is there anything we can take in here?
Oh my god, they also have Catty in here.
She's the hot stuff.
Okay, so 15?
15.
Sorry, I heard like a...
Alright, 15, 15.
Shirtless dudes also scare me.
Suddenly became Metal Gear.
Sorry, I brought up Metal Gear again.
Sorry.
Sorry, brain rot.
Please excuse my brain rot.
Rotate right.
215.
Okay.
Now we just have a red.
Which I feel like we could just guess.
And then something will happen once it's correct, right?
Do I really have to go?
I feel like we could just guess.
And then whenever I get it correct, something happens.
Right?
What is Metal Gear?
What isn't Metal Gear?
Metal Gear is a state of mind.
Metal Gear is...
Be careful.
No?
Okay.
I'm hyping myself up.
Oh, that's right.
It was in here.
Yeah, Metal Gear is a way of life.
Okay,
it goes up this way.
So I really didn't need to go in here at all.
Oh, and then it goes to here.
Oh, push.
Push.
Wow, it's the most silent...
Is it good?
It's the most...
Ten!
Okay.
It's the most silent locker I've ever heard.
I've never heard, because I didn't hear a dang thing.
I just tuned in.
Is this game scary?
I think it has a good atmosphere.
And sometimes it has some jump scares, yes.
But, I don't know, I wouldn't say...
It's super duper scary.
Oh god, don't jump out of me from the pool again, please.
I'm crazier than you.
I'll literally rip your tongue out with my teeth.
Okay.
Alright, ten.
It was ten.
Ten, ten, ten, ten.
Ten.
Rotate right.
You've returned water to the hotel.
There were no instructions.
That guy was so full of shit.
Okay, we're good now?
I think.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Just run.
I'm running.
Oh god, not that way.
Oh my god.
Run!
I have such good stamina.
Get out of here!
Oh, not that way.
Run!
Maybe into that vent?
Okay.
Climb!
Climb, climb, climb, please.
Oh my god.
Good thing this thing is so slow.
I think we better get out of here.
Sounds like an actual T-Rex.
I think...
Do I have to avoid that thing again?
Goth GF, where did you go?
Where do I go?
I think I just messed up you guys.
I think I should have run through the other door.
That's my bad.
Find and rescue the diaper chief, Donald Anderson.
You slapped me to death for real.
Okay.
Wait, the door is open.
I'm running.
I'm running, running, running.
I'm running, I'm running.
I'm getting out of here.
She could have just kept going.
I think the door glitched out.
The glore.
What's wrong with me?
It's just me combining words again you guys.
Oh god.
Climb, climb, climb.
Okay.
Our little brisk jog.
So I guess we go to the...
It does let me run.
We go to here.
Oh my god.
Okay, not that way.
Okay, now we are avoiding electricity.
Love that.
Can't we lure him into the electricity?
I don't feel like I'm running fast enough.
I really don't feel like I'm running fast enough for this guy.
Hi, dag!
Oh my god.
Into here?
Your brain works faster than your mouth.
Damn!
Oh my god.
How do you feel?
Feel nice and safe in there?
Yeah, I bet you did.
I'm fine.
Who was it?
How did you end up here?
I'm fine, thank you.
How are you?
We are trying to be nice to her, so let's ask if she's okay.
Are you alright?
Do you need a hug?
Are you okay?
Yeah, I wonder what caused that.
Okay, let's go together.
Oh good.
It's really red.
Oh my god, we are right here.
That's kind of awesome.
It's like I'm at home again.
Yeah, you can take a shower.
Okay.
Hello?
Was it you who cut the power?
I was attacked.
I had no other choice.
You destroyed our only link to the outside world.
I hope it was worth it.
This guy is such a jerk!
Do I have to end the world for Goth GF?
Is that the requirement?
I think it will help.
I was close to...
Sorry.
I was close to getting a signal out, but now everything is gone haywire.
Alright kid.
I need to check the manual and see if it can be fixed.
Head back to your room.
The corridors aren't safe right now.
My cameras are no longer working.
See you soon.
Oh good.
Is that us sleeping?
And save!
Oh no!
Our dreams are getting really more vivid now.
They're getting really bright.
Wait, which way do I go?
This way?
What if I go this way?
Good luck everyone else.
4K dreaming.
The ocean is getting so bright and vivid now.
Am I going the right way?
Does it matter?
Oh, ok.
I hit the invisible wall.
Yeah, we dream in Subnautica.
It's because we're a gamer.
We dream in video games and everything.
Nice.
Where is our...
Where is our space lady?
There she is.
Hello space lady!
What is that?
Oh, it's a giant...
It's a giant spout.
Our cosmic GF.
She's like watching us as we run around like a little kid in a candy store.
Hello!
You tried to help them.
You almost died.
And what in the end?
Everything only got worse.
And they treated you like crap.
You know what?
That is true.
I, I, I...
Well, not Robin.
She was nice.
But the guy is such a jerk.
Oh.
Stay silent.
I brought back the water to help myself, not them.
You're exaggerating their reaction.
They owe me for this.
Is this even the same game?
What if I just stay silent?
I wonder.
I feel like it goes from like...
From like agreement to disagreement, you know.
Or actually, I don't think so.
They owe me for this is not really disagreeing.
I think 3 is probably the most anti-space GF.
So you risk your life for them and they paid you with nagging?
Of course.
That's much better.
Before you know it, you and only you will have to solve their problems again.
I have a feeling she's not wrong.
They can rely on you, but you can't rely on them.
Robin is helping me.
The watcher is trying to contact the rescuers.
The priest is hunting monsters.
We're including the priest?
He's part of our entourage?
He doesn't even go here.
I have to trust someone.
I think we can say Robin is helping me.
She came with.
I mean, it's not her fault.
She probably just stumbled upon that monster.
Robin is helping me.
She's with you only because you protect her.
She's a thief and you've already realized that.
What?
A thief?
You know that she's hiding something even more dangerous.
Where did we get thief from?
They will betray you if you rely on them, as it was then.
Yeah, she stole my heart.
You will be alone again.
Broken.
Then you will remember why you came here.
I don't want this, but maybe it's worth reminding what it's like.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Open the valve.
Opening?
We have rusty pipes.
Wait, it's going to overflow I think.
Ma'am?
Ma'am, stop the valve.
Are we OK?
Day 8.
Did we get another achievement?
Yup.
Survive until the 8th day.
Wait, we are in the bed.
The bathroom?
Wait, we slept in the bed actually.
Uh oh, it doesn't look so good out there you guys.
Wait, she's in the bathroom?
Guys...
OK, I'm checking my breath.
I'm checking my hair.
Do I look OK?
OK.
Oh my gosh, I also like to shower like a monkey.
She's scratching her head.
See, I told you we should have gone to that...
Remember that guy that stole all the soap?
We should have grabbed his stuff.
You're welcome.
I may not believe it, but when we were kids...
we didn't have a shower or even running water inside our house.
Oh my god, no shower?
We should have soaked back.
At least, that's what my parents would definitely say.
I mean, if you take like a 30 minute shower, yeah, probably.
But I think that sometimes small joys can give us strength to face something big.
Could you pass us the coat?
Thanks.
Oh yeah, sure, I got you.
There you go.
I don't need it.
I never cope.
Do you want to take a shower?
You know, it's a great stress reliever.
Of course, why not?
Good thinking.
You'll like it.
Just wait until I'm done.
I'm almost there.
Right.
What's that thing?
Save water...
Save a dolphin, ride a cowboy.
Save water, shower with me.
Wait, what is it?
Save water, ride a cowgirl?
Am I getting the saying right?
Use the gum.
Yeah, I need to use the gum.
She hates us.
What are you talking about, Robin?
We've been together for 8 days.
We've been together for just a little bit over a week and you haven't fallen in love with me?
We haven't trauma bonded enough?
It's been 8 days and you're not gonna propose?
Developer...
Developer, you sneaky...
Sneaky bastard, you.
She's getting dressed.
Wow, that was fast.
Thank you, I will.
I like how...
We have the candle in the shower.
Actually, how did that stay lit?
Now that I think about it.
She's so cute.
Turn off please.
Don't turn it back on.
Oh my god, she is so cute!
Gosh, look at her!
Oh my gosh, her face is probably so cute.
Okay, excuse me!
Pick up!
Hello!
It's me.
Who is me?
Your pal, the Watcher.
Who else would be calling you?
Hey, you're snarky with me all the time.
I can be snarky with you.
She's out of our league.
No, no, no.
We got this.
We're probably so handsome.
I figured out the issue.
The emergency generator has shut off.
It needs to be restarted.
It's located underground, but to reach it you'll have to go through the parking lot.
But why can't you?
And no, I can't do this myself.
Don't even ask.
This guy is such a jerk.
I know we know the reason why now, but just communicate that to us.
Like, he doesn't know that we read that note.
You know?
I'm nearly done setting up the radio transmitter.
I need to finish this.
Head down to me.
I'll pass you the keys to the parking lot.
See you soon, kid.
Okay.
Go without me.
I need to do something.
Uh, what are you up to?
I can't say.
You'll find out later.
I'll see you later, okay?
Uh...
Hey, Robin.
This might be a bad time to bring this up, but I'm infected.
And, you know, I told the voices inside my head that you were the only one helping me out.
And, like, you know, it's kind of putting off the infection from, like, spreading any further.
But you're really not helping my case if you just, like, don't... if you don't help me out.
Because I literally, in my dreams, was like, oh, Robin is the only one I can depend on.
And you're just really throwing that case away.
I'm just saying.
Good luck.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Thank you.
You're really not gonna come with?
How much food do we have left, even?
We definitely did not have seven days worth of food.
Alright.
Wipes your eyes.
I'm, like, sobbing.
I'm crying.
And she's like, wipes your tears away.
Good luck.
Wipes off your face.
Oh my god.
Robin, it's really dark out here.
Robin.
I think it would be good if we quit together.
As a team.
What is that?
Who's laughing?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
This is so bad.
In here?
Yep.
Oh my god, it's the white lady.
Gosh.
You.
Hi, white lady.
Come here.
Okay.
Gosh.
She's so demanding.
I kind of love her.
You covered him up.
Hello.
I saw you with her.
Young, beautiful.
You went to buy tickets.
She's still hallucinating.
You...
Are you breaking up with me?
She's remembering the moment when her husband left.
If I don't direct this fantasy of hers, everything could end very badly.
Please snap out of it.
I'm not your husband.
These are tickets to a resort.
I was preparing a surprise for you.
I have to go on a business trip.
Okay, definitely not that one.
You're mistaken.
It wasn't me.
I'm either to two or four.
One or four?
Like, do we play along with it?
Or do we be like, girl...
Girl, you out your mind.
What would Raiden pick?
Four.
Of course.
Like, I'm supposed to believe that.
Okay, Raiden, definitely, this would happen.
Who is she?
That girl you were with.
Blonde hair, pink dress, car, Barbie?
Oh my gosh.
No, black hair, black t-shirt, hotel.
Or...
She's starting to mix them up.
It seems her mind is starting to clear.
No, no, no.
Who are you with?
Tell me!
I was just giving my sister a ride.
A colleague from work was helping me.
Spendgum.
Why look for fake stones when a real diamond is waiting at home?
How do these work on her?
They were different people you saw at different times.
There was no girl.
Maybe this?
Because her mind is starting to clear, right?
There were different people you saw at different times.
Honey came in and she caught me red-handed creeping with the girl next door.
Oh, see, that worked.
Different times.
Oh, she's confused.
Oh my god.
It worked!
Blonde in the car.
Or...
Girl at the hotel.
Hotel.
I didn't come here alone.
Oh, she's starting to really realize.
A guy whose name I don't remember.
I took him away from his family.
Like she took you away from me.
Yeah, because he was married.
He's a scumbag though, don't worry.
He chose this room.
Our room.
And he didn't even know about it.
This is one weird dating sim, right?
I kind of want like a horror dating sim now.
It's kind of awesome.
A horndog.
Like all of them.
You ain't nothing but a horndog.
Crying all the time.
Wasn't mint.
No, it wasn't me.
The shadows in the corners are getting stronger.
I barely remember myself.
Was it me?
Who killed him?
Do I lay this upon her?
Yes, no, I don't know.
I mean, I guess we...
It's probably her, right?
Be honest?
Yes, I knew it.
The voice suggested it and I did it.
And it felt good.
I close my eyes and I see myself beside him.
We're laughing, dancing.
You're taking game suggestions.
Am I?
Right now?
It's a caveman ghost world.
Interesting.
Sucker for love is a lovecraft dating sim.
Oh, true?
But I want something a little more...
I want something a little more freaky.
Scary.
He's leading me and I let him lead.
The shadow.
If she told me what to do...
Who's at fault?
Me or her?
People died because of your weakness.
It's not your fault.
Someone's using you or something's using you.
It's up to you to decide.
Yeah, Slay the Princess is very much like that.
Three?
Let's do three.
It's hard to decide.
Is he to blame?
Am I?
Or is she?
Are we all in... She?
Is her voice also a lady?
Or is she talking about the other woman?
Yeah, is she also seeing the cosmic GF?
Or are we all...
Are we all in this together?
We're all in this together.
The voice whispers not only to me.
You hear it too, don't you?
It pretended to be my husband.
It will give you what you're looking for.
I think mine is pretending to be my mom then.
Scarisol.
Horror dating sim.
Not a dating sim for horror monsters.
Yeah, the bot fanbook makes sense.
It will become a part of you.
Go.
I kind of like the white lady so much.
I won't see you again.
No, white lady!
I got an achievement.
You said goodbye to the white lady.
I can kind of see her face.
She's beautiful.
White lady!
I'll catch you on the flip side.
It's so tragic.
I know.
I'm gonna miss her.
God.
Red means scary.
It's so red.
Don't go, white lady.
Don't go.
Our fishy dreams are...
Oh my god.
It's getting so freaky here.
Oh.
It's getting so freaky.
Yeah, that's not supposed to happen while we're awake.
Oh jeez.
I think we're in trouble.
Where did Robin go?
She stayed in the room.
She said she was preparing something, but what does that mean?
Oh god.
I hope there's no monster here.
I need gum.
I guess we don't need the gum anymore.
Alright.
We can see outside.
It's actually way cleaner than I thought it would be.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Oh, we are so... we are so borked.
Oh my god, we are so in trouble.
Oh no.
We are so in trouble.
We are so infected.
Oh my god.
Can't determine reality.
Wait, there was water right here!
Are you kidding me?
We could have survived on this for a little bit.
Oh my god.
We are so... this is so bad.
We can't determine anything.
What's real?
What's fiction?
We don't know anymore.
Oh god.
Um, excuse me?
Mr. Security man, I can't hold my breath under here.
Knock on the door.
Ah, it's you.
Head to the main exit and turn right.
There will be a staircase to the parking lot behind the door.
Here's the key for it.
Oh, thank you.
Parking key.
I need to go downstairs to fix the light.
Go down there and find the generator room.
That's all.
Off you go, kid.
I've got work to do.
Not a good luck or anything?
It seems like he's still mad at me.
If he is so smart, he should go there himself.
No good luck or anything.
This guy is such a jerk.
So we go to the main... Oh, parking.
I see it.
Oh, we couldn't go this way before.
Oh, okay, okay.
Do it yourself.
I don't think whatever... I think the monster is telling the birds to shut up.
Whatever monster is out there.
Shut the hell up, bird.
What's in here?
We will never know.
Rip croaky.
Alright.
Into the parking lot, which is underground.
Lucky us.
I love that for us.
Okay, anything over here?
Doesn't seem to be the case.
Alright.
Oh gosh.
Is there anything...
No notes or anything of the sort?
Surely no one died in the parking garage, right?
Oh, read the note.
I was scolded again for falling asleep.
I can't help it.
I have such beautiful dreams.
And the voice... I close my eyes and I still hear it.
I just don't know what he's saying.
I need to listen.
Do you guys hear that?
I don't think... I don't think we are alone in here.
Oh no.
Of course we are not alone in here.
That would be ridiculous.
Oh gosh.
Where do I go?
Do I already have to watch out for a monster?
Or am I good until I get to the generator?
Okay, I'm careful.
I'm careful.
Oh god, I'm careful.
Oh, I thought that was a monster right there.
My heart jumped.
Here, I'll turn it down a little bit.
Oh my gosh, a cyber truck.
There's another car that's on.
Where do I go?
Do I go towards the light?
Maybe?
Seems to be the case.
There's a thing over here.
Okay, again.
How are all the cars... How did this happen?
You know, like...
You...
You didn't...
Like, that couldn't... How did you park like this?
When... What?
Were you trying to like...
Wait.
Wait, what's down here real quick?
Hold on.
Before we get the phone.
Like, were you in such a rush that you...
Okay.
Oh!
There's a camera.
It's working.
The lights down here are working.
Now that I think about it.
Okay.
Alright.
Hello?
Close the door.
Pick up the phone.
Hello?
Are you okay?
I noticed some movement near you on the cameras.
Be careful.
What?
How is that possible?
Huh?
Isn't the issue that we don't have power so that you need me to start the generator so that you can see on the cameras?
Can you explain what I need to do?
There are plenty of cars here.
Why not drive off in one?
That sounds stupid.
Who did you see on the cameras?
I'm ready.
A pale creature without eyes.
Your girlfriend called it a craw...
My girl...
My...
Girlfriend?
Maybe it only works here.
Maybe.
Crawler.
Okay, so it's the guy that... Okay, that would make sense why he... Why the alarm went off and then he broke it.
Be quiet.
It seems to be drawn to you.
Okay.
Can you explain what I need to do?
There's an emergency generator near you, okay?
It should be in a working condition.
It's just out of fuel.
Find a canister and siphon off some gas from a couple of cars.
As soon as you fill the tank, start the generator.
There are plenty of cars here.
Okay, I'm gonna ask this even though I think it's kind of silly.
I wouldn't recommend it.
Several guests tried to do that on the first day.
I can still see their wrecked cars on the external cameras.
You wouldn't want to run into what's out there on the streets.
I'm ready.
Alright, take a canister and siphon off some gas, then refuel the generator and start it.
And one more thing.
Okay, Columbo.
Once the emergency lights kick in, the elevator will start working too.
Use it to go up to the top floor.
I've finished setting up the transmitter, but I need you to make some tweaks to the antenna.
If everything goes well, we'll contact the rescuers today.
Good luck, kid.
Okay, seems like this is our final challenge.
Alright, it just saved, so cool.
If I die, we're good.
Oh my goodness, why is it lagging all of a sudden?
He saw how I watched him from around the corner and he understood everything.
He knows what I'm thinking.
He knows what I'm doing.
He senses who I am inside.
I need to stay away from him.
What does that mean?
He said good luck.
Yeah, he finally said it!
Okay, alright.
So we put it into here and then we pull that, I guess?
This thing looks ancient.
No wonder it broke down.
We don't have to do anything else here?
Electrical hazard?
No?
Okay.
I wish I could crawl.
You know?
What cars are good to siphon gas from?
There he is.
Oh my god.
No!
Okay, good.
He turned that way.
Let's get all the cars that are close to us first.
Right?
Or not?
Can we get this car?
Where is the gas?
Where is the...
Where is the hole for the gas?
Okay, nevermind.
Understandable.
I hope this doesn't take me several tries.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of this one.
I don't want it to take me a long time.
I'm scared.
Maybe here?
Oh, an electric vehicle.
Probably, right?
Where did he... Oh, okay.
How close can I be to him?
Siphon gas.
Does it make a lot of sound?
Oh my god.
Okay, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god.
He's coming this way.
We need to get out of here.
Pronto.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll come for that one last.
That was so close.
Holy cannoli.
Oh my god.
Stop following me.
Please.
Stop following me, please.
Don't turn around.
I hate you.
This is messed up.
I was literally just about to stand right there.
This is so messed up.
Mister.
This is stressing me the hell out.
I'm not gonna lie.
Get the gas.
I don't know how this is working, but whatever.
I wonder if he runs into me.
Okay, he's all the way over there.
Maybe what?
Like two more cars?
The blue car.
Yeah, I'm gonna go for that one last.
Gonna go for that one last.
Yeah, I can't look around while he's siphoning.
I know it's scary.
Do you think one or two?
I can't tell.
I also don't know where he is at all.
Mister.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he's far.
But actually I need to go back that way.
If he could not do that, actually.
Okay, I think we just need one more so we can go back to the blue car, probably.
Actually, why would I do that if this one has it?
You know what?
He's far.
Actually, where is he?
We'll just sneak past on the way over there, I think.
Okay, I think we're good.
Okay, it just saved!
Oh my gosh, the game is so kind.
Wow, it just saved.
So I guess if I die at this part trying to head back...
I don't have to collect all the gas again.
The game is actually so kind.
Please, please, please, please.
Can I run?
Okay, seems like I can run.
Well, jog.
Whatever you call this.
I can't... What was that?
Did he notice me?
No.
He didn't notice me, right?
Actually... Oh, the elevator.
I think it's down here.
So we will keep that open.
Okay, pour the gasoline.
Walking slightly fast.
Okay, and it's full, baby.
Nice.
What do I hear behind there?
Oh my God, no way.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh my God.
No, no, no, no.
Please, please, please, please, please hurry.
Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God.
It's on!
Oh my God.
Elevator!
I think we are so dead.
Wait, did he shoot me?
No, he shot the monster.
He aimed it right at my head!
How am I alive?
Come in.
Priest!
Why were you in there?
Priest, how did...
Wait, were you just locked in the elevator?
Maybe I should thank you.
Thank you!
There is no need for gratitude.
Stop the elevator.
Wait, no?
Are you sure?
Why?
Stop the elevator.
He is so demanding.
Oh my God.
Stop the elevator.
I'm stopping it?
I stopped it?
Yeah?
What is that going to do?
Good.
I think you need like a suppressor on that thing, man.
There are creatures in here that are really sensitive to sound.
Young woman.
She was walking next to you a few days ago.
Why do creepy things never have eyes?
Why no ears or nose?
I don't know.
It's like...
To get the creepy buff, you have to lose one of the five senses.
I almost said six senses.
Sorry, I'm a ghost.
Describe her.
But remember, lying is a sin.
Oh, and sinners will face God's punishment.
Just an acquaintance, nothing special.
I don't understand what you mean.
No, no, no.
He wants me to describe her.
Black clothes.
Wait, black hair, dark clothes.
Energetic.
Alright, you can't describe her face.
I described her!
What do you want me to say about her face?
Little tiny button nose and big anime eyeballs.
And a fang.
One of her teeth is a fang.
What do you want me to say?
What's her name?
I can't say I don't know her name.
I either lie or...
I can't say that I don't know her name because I've been with her for...
I've been with her for eight days.
There's no way.
I think I should tell the truth.
Robin.
Interesting.
The girl I'm looking for was named Robin.
Guys, I think I messed up.
Snitches get stitches.
He has a gun pointed...
I'm literally staring down this barrel right now.
What are you talking about?
She had light hair and was dressed in simple modest clothing.
Robin is a really popular name.
Maybe it's her.
Maybe not.
She betrayed her parents.
Stole from the community of simple God-fearing people.
I came to guide her back to the righteous path.
I thought he was going to be her father.
Also, this man's yaoi hands...
Wait, does he have six fingers?
One, two, three, four...
Does he have...
Bro has grippers.
Does he have really...
I don't think it's AI.
I think his hands are just... I think this part is what's throwing me off.
It's like a big chunk of his hand.
It's just funky looking.
It's a funny pose, I think.
Nice gifted mintsub.
Thank you.
Do you think this is the girl you saw?
No, it's another girl.
You think so?
Alright, my son.
I'll take your word for it.
I've been waiting for this a long time.
Waiting for what?
When God pays attention to the sin of the earth.
The weak transform into their aspirations and destroy each other.
You want to get out?
That's why you're going upstairs.
To call for rescue.
But one of you has already fallen prey to the devil.
He's already heeding it's whispers.
Do you know who?
I don't know.
Don't lie to me.
It's me!
The world has shown God it's true nature.
And he is displeased.
I hear his voice.
Oh, you're hearing voices!
Oh yeah, this guy is totally infected.
I still don't know which one of you harbors the devil.
But I won't let him escape.
This is my floor.
See you around.
Until we meet again.
I sure hope not.
Where did the buttons go?
We're at the rooftop.
The lady in white said we won't meet again.
Oh my gosh.
God, that scared me.
Hello?
Oh, she's here!
Robin!
I was going to say the birds are gone, but clearly they're not.
Is it still party time?
They even took down...
They even took down the party time flyer?
That's so sad.
Hello?
Try to fix what?
Aww, Robin.
See, she's not bad.
She'll show me the world.
Wait.
Our apple and our banana.
Even our Doritos are rotting.
There's a person standing down there.
Oh my god, I think that's the first time we've ever seen anything standing outside of the hotel.
Any creature.
It's probably infected, but that's kind of crazy.
Oh my god.
It's starting to lag a little bit for me again.
Even our Doritos were like brown.
Wasn't this thing already fixed?
I can do it.
Oh okay, I know how to do this.
Pick up the phone.
Hello?
Hey kid, glad you made it.
I would not have made it without the priest though.
The girl wanted to help, but she is a total zero in any sort of tech.
I found settings that will help us contact rescuers.
We need to check them.
You already know the drill.
Set the voltage to 13 volts and tune in the wave.
Wait, it says 12.
Are you sure?
Psycho Mantis?
I'm on the phone.
I know what to do.
I have to do math.
Oh man.
Wait.
Oh, it's at 12.
I have to set it to...
Oh, okay, just kidding.
It's at 12.
I have to set it to 13.
Let's see.
It said 8 earlier.
Maybe he updated it.
I have to do math.
Okay.
Okay, I know.
Oh, whoops.
3, 2, 8.
I got it all on my own.
Alright, next is this thing.
Tune the antenna.
We got to rotate this right a little.
Wait, did that do anything?
Rotate it right.
Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Pull the lever that's located to the right of the phone.
Let me out.
Okay, hold on.
There's order of operations here.
It's not working.
Damn.
No!
Something's wrong.
Days of work down the drain.
No!
Maybe we should increase the voltage.
Make it display 18 volts and change the wave to a new one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Why?
I just did the math.
Come on.
Hold on.
I'm not looking at chat.
It needs to be 18.
7, 5, 6.
Okay.
I did it?
And now I did this?
Oh, to make it teeny tiny.
Turn the antenna.
Rotate to left.
We have to make it so short and small.
Like so.
Rotate left.
Okay, now rotate right.
And right again.
Okay.
How would the frequency... Why would we need to change the frequency?
Wandering Taco!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
I don't know what else can be done.
Is it not an electricity thing?
Ah, to hell with it.
Just crank the voltage to the max and pull the lever.
What have we got to lose anyway?
So true.
Okay, max.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, pull it!
It worked!
Oh my god, we are going to call for help.
It worked kid!
I'm sending a signal to the rescuers.
If it works, we'll get an answer soon.
Now let's wait guys.
Let's wait.
I like how they just... You know what?
After all this time, I really like that they just assumed that there were rescuers.
That were coming, you know?
Like just...
They're like, oh yeah, there's got to be some people out there that will pick us up.
Alright.
Is it the picnic?
I kind of spoiled myself, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry Robin, I saw it.
I still only see the what is...
Okay, chill out.
Hold on.
Do you think that's the voice?
I wonder.
Because it's the only person I see.
I wonder if that's the voice.
Come on!
So needy, I know.
I like her that way.
Hello.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, she's so beautiful in the...
In the apocalyptic sunlight.
It'll be difficult if we consider the view.
Thank you, that's very nice.
I think it's too dangerous.
Okay, we're not going to be like Raiden here because Raiden would say the wrong answer.
So thank you.
That's very nice.
I mean if we die, at least we die in style.
It's very important for me.
Let's stay just for a couple of minutes and wait for an answer.
Yeah.
And if we'll not receive it, we'll just leave.
Okay.
Can you like turn off the radio though?
Because it's just static.
Well, why are you just sitting?
Take some food.
Help yourself.
Oh my god, this is actually dangerous.
Wait a second.
Girl, don't do it Robin.
Robin, no!
Oh my god, that is the biggest bird I've ever seen.
Holy shit, they didn't scale the bird for like how far away he is.
So he's actually just ginormous.
Wait!
I see another person standing down there.
Maybe it isn't the voice.
Maybe it's just creepy infected people.
I'm eating.
How do you like it?
Rotten banana.
Delish.
Even the plate is nasty.
We couldn't even rinse that under...
Oh, this thing is starting to mold.
This is very tasty.
Thank you.
I'm gonna... You know what?
It's starting to mold.
Sorry, we don't have much food left.
Oh, I didn't mean to make her sad.
Listen.
I want to tell you something.
This is it guys.
The confession.
I lied to you.
But you probably already guessed it yourself.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
I ran away from home.
You are so quiet, Robin.
Please.
This wasn't an ordinary house.
I can't hear you.
We were extremely religious.
Is that why she became a goth babe?
We were taught to be free of the outside world.
They divided everyone into two groups.
The faithful and the damned.
We were punished for the smallest mistakes.
Is she getting quieter?
It feels like it, right?
It's so quiet.
Do you know what was the worst?
All this crap that happened there.
There we go.
I thought it was normal.
And that's how the world works.
I think if I look at her, she's really quiet.
One day, I just decided that I couldn't do it anymore.
I ran away.
You got this.
Did you steal something from them?
What did they do to you?
Did you run away alone?
Did you run away with any...
Any... you know...
Fellers with you?
Anyone else that...
But the guy called her a thief.
So she must have stolen something.
Crew, thanks for the five gifts.
Thank you.
Any boyfriends?
What did they do to you?
Poor girl.
He's been kind of a thorn in my side, but thank god he's around at the same time.
He hasn't knocked down our door yet.
He's probably busy with his crusade.
I can't imagine a better situation for him.
Robin, you need to speak up or at least turn the radio off.
Get her emperor!
Thanks for the five gifted!
I hope you can get out of here before you hurt members about me.
Yeah, me too.
Okay, let's change the subject.
Yeah, let's talk about our relationship.
He ate something.
Or did I cook all this for him?
Well, not cooked, but I brought it here.
Yeah, that's literally what I was gonna say.
I was gonna say, girl cooked?
She cooked.
I'm eating the apple.
She's poisoning me.
Maybe.
No, I think... I don't think Robin will...
I don't think there's gonna be a twist.
If there's a twist, it's gonna be the Watcher, right?
Actually, I have no idea.
Maybe Robin is the bringer of the apocalypse.
And the priest is like, I told you so, man.
Maybe this is all because of her.
And he was just coming to...
You know, it's one of those situations where it's like I have to kill her or else the apocalypse will never end.
We might be the baddies.
I don't know.
That would suck.
No, I'll say, aren't you afraid to be alone?
If you are, Robin.
I'm right here for you, baby.
Who said I'm alone?
The world is full of people...
The Vizel thinks you're the five gifted.
Even in this place, trapped in this hotel, we found each other.
True.
And we found the Watcher guy.
Although he is a bit strange.
We found each other.
See, it's working, it's working.
I'm sure of it.
We all have our secrets.
Your problems with communication?
Nightmares?
Being infected.
That's a silly one, though.
We don't talk about that.
Lost your parents, right?
Also, I just noticed these like giant cables coming out from the buildings and like attaching to...
What the hell are these?
What are these giant cables?
When I was in your room...
I saw the documents from the child protection services.
Sorry, I was complaining to you about my parents...
They're power cables, but like...
Well, you know.
Do they attach to building to building like that?
I don't have anyone.
Maybe that's the problem.
I'm curious.
What brought you to the hotel?
I just have a feeling it's not a fun occasion.
Truth.
I wanted to end all my problems at once.
Lie.
I was just looking for a place to think about the future.
I don't want to talk about it.
She didn't want to talk about it.
Tell the truth?
Trust in her?
Listen.
I know things don't look good right now.
But what I want to see is this.
Sorry.
I know things don't look good right now, but...
I just want to say this.
That kind of sounds like...
I'm Deku.
And I'm quirkless.
But one day I hope to become the greatest hero.
Just like my idol.
All Might.
Especially in this line.
I couldn't unhear it.
Lie.
You value me only because I'm useful.
My feelings...
Guys, it's time.
My feelings go beyond friendship.
If she rejects me, I can end it all right now.
I'm also glad that I met you.
I acted on my own self-interest.
My feelings go beyond friendship.
I wonder.
I'm so curious.
Oh, I...
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you?
Oh wait, what does that... I appreciate it.
You know...
To be honest...
I'm already blessed.
That's it.
Just jump from the ledge right here, buddy.
You better hope that that banana was poisoned.
Do a flip, Miki.
She changed the subject.
She changed the...
It hurts.
I came to this hotel to end all my problems at once.
Oh, yeah.
That's okay.
I'm glad we met each other.
Actually, I really like you.
I appreciate it.
Fail out.
Wait, what do you mean before it's all over?
Are we gonna die?
How does the rejection feel?
Tastes like moldy banana.
No!
Our food is gone.
Actually, now I think about it, I think all the monsters inside...
Well, besides the woman.
I wonder what she did.
But all the other monsters that we've encountered are gone.
There weren't that many.
There was only like the two of them.
Why did it get so ominous all of a sudden?
What's wrong?
What do you mean?
I what?
What's wrong?
Green ghost is down.
Someone get a medic.
Message from the rescue services.
The request from the Sanity Inn Hotel has been accepted.
An evacuation of civilians is scheduled for 8pm tomorrow.
Tomorrow?
All survivors are advised to make their way to the roof and await the arrival of a rescue team.
Thank god.
At least we...
At least we have our Doritos.
Tomorrow?
My rejection has manifested.
Wait, did she just try to kiss us?
Guys...
Um...
The last day.
Oh no.
I pretend not to see.
Let's just get this over with.
I hear whispers even.
Fight it Mint.
We're fighting?
Hello Galaxy Mama.
It's even worse than I thought.
Minto is allergic to goth girls.
I felt like a static shock.
Hello...
Ma'am?
Huh?
What?
Oh my god.
Oh, poor girl.
She's probably so freaked out.
I don't think so.
Something is calling me.
I guess I was just walking in my sleep.
Everything is fine.
Don't worry about it.
No, I think I gotta tell her.
I think we have to tell her.
Yeah...
I scream in my sleep?
That's a new one.
I'm just asleep.
This is not what I meant by need a medic.
I don't know what you're talking about.
How do you know about her?
Someone talks to me.
Yeah, how do you know about her?
You mumble something while you sleep.
I'm just spilling all my secrets.
I don't want to mention it.
I thought you were just having nightmares.
But something is clearly wrong here.
Oh my god, I just remembered.
We have that guy in 311 as well.
We gotta get that guy out too.
You're infected.
Oh god.
This will never end.
Rescuers will arrive soon.
Resculers?
You want to redo that line, Robin?
Yeah, I'm not one of those people that's gonna...
In a zombie apocalypse, it's like...
I got bit, but like...
Maybe I'm different.
Go on without me, Robin.
Go on without me.
We'll fly away and tell them nothing.
Oh my gosh.
I'll tell them and hope for the best.
You'll fly.
And I will stay.
Oh Robin.
Robin.
I mean, if I'm infected, I won't get killed, right?
True.
No, wait.
No, Robin.
I'm sure.
Yeah, all two of them.
Priest.
I think we...
Leave that guy here.
I don't think we should bring him.
I don't...
He's...
I think he's infected.
He must fly away with us.
He must not.
It is not our responsibility.
I make so much noise when I sleep.
That one girl remarked, how can you love...
How can anyone love you when you make that much noise?
What?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
She changed her tune so quickly.
As soon as I was like, nah, fuck that guy.
No, my man, Priest.
Exactly.
We wouldn't know how to find him.
That guy is like...
He's a lone wolf.
That guy can handle his own.
He doesn't need to come with us.
That guy has...
His own demons.
Literally.
He's in the elevator?
Yeah, we'll just find him in the elevator again.
Hello?
Yeah.
Moshi moshi.
It's time for us to get ready, kid.
But I need help.
Are you infected?
What?
No, no, just...
I'm disabled, kid.
I can hardly do anything on my own.
A friend from the army...
Got me this job.
He said it's a cushy position.
Just watch the cameras and call the police...
If anything happens.
Oh my gosh.
His phone guy.
You can't lift your butt off your wheelchair anyway.
At least here you'll have something to do.
And then all this started.
You've been lying to me this whole time.
Why are you so angry?
Why didn't you say anything?
Because I was scared, kid.
I'm still scared.
What if you decide to break into me and take all my supplies?
What if that crazy holy man does it?
I was stuck in this damn room.
On this damn wheelchair and I watched people die.
I was responsible for them.
How could I call myself a security guard if I cannot guard?
I just look at these damn monitors.
This poor guy.
Yeah, they would break into his office.
I wanted to be useful.
And I tried to be as useful as I could.
I'm sorry.
I relied on you so much.
Yeah, that guy's been sitting there for like a week.
He probably pooped his pants.
Realistically.
And we're gonna have to ride in the same helicopter as him.
I want everybody to be prepared.
That...
He probably doesn't have a bathroom in there.
And he's probably just been sitting in his own poop for a week.
I'd rather he say he was infected.
The smelly watcher.
You guys just have to be prepared, okay?
We'll still take him.
But we have to prepare ourselves.
For the poopening.
It's okay, we're helping each other.
You have nothing to apologize for, I understand.
How can I trust you now?
Be glad you're locked in there.
Otherwise I'd smash your head in with your own wheelchair.
Oh
my god!
I kinda wanna pick it because it's so out of pocket.
Oh my god!
I'm a monster!
Did it save?
Could I, like, do it?
Pick it?
I wonder if he's just like...
Raiden's inner thoughts.
Oh my gosh.
We've been playing the good guy this whole time.
Sometimes I like to play...
a little bit of a...
instigator in these things.
But we've been playing it pretty good this whole time.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I wanna be a little...
ass wipe next time though.
I wanna be someone who's just such a...
jerk to everybody.
You have nothing to apologize.
It's okay.
Thank you, Ken.
Thank you.
I have one last request and I hope you'll agree to fulfill it.
Come down here and help me get to the roof.
I'll open the door so we can finally meet in person.
Alright?
What's... Is there anything else you wanna tell me?
Yes, kid.
One more thing.
My name...
Columbo.
I saw how you look around the corners while walking through the corridors.
As if you're talking to someone or seeing those...
Seeing those who aren't there.
Oh.
You're infected.
I know it.
Knew it for a long time.
But you've been fighting this infection much longer than the others.
And I believe that you will not give in to it.
So he knew and still helps us.
And if you decide not to tell anyone about it, I will remain silent too.
He actually is such a good guy.
Because I trust in you.
Oh.
See you soon.
Wow.
Okay, Robin.
You listen...
She's probably right on top of me.
Breathing down my neck listening to these conversations.
I just realized...
On the rooftop...
To get to the roof roof area...
It's all stairs.
How are we gonna move him?
Still should've picked 4.
I know.
I hope that it will never...
Oh, I lost hope that it will never end.
I was like, you hope it never ends?
Robin, what's wrong with you?
Okay.
I'll see you down there, Robin.
I'll see you down there.
What was that sound?
Oh my god.
He was here?
All the writing is gone?
Except...
Mine for some reason.
Okay, let's go.
He wasn't here though.
Oh, yes he was.
Just kidding.
Guy made sure to take care of every room.
Hey, hey buddy.
Who's there?
Is that you, young man?
Did something happen?
Wow, imagine if I was like...
Nope, nothing.
See you later.
Rescue is on its way.
Get ready.
That would be such an asshole move.
You're not joking?
That's wonderful.
I need to prepare.
Go without me, young man.
I'll get myself up...
Or I'll get up myself as soon as I gather my strength.
And young man, thank you for everything you've done.
I owe you my life.
I'm glad there are still people in the world who can be relied upon.
And I'm fortunate that one of them happens to be my next door neighbor.
Next...
We're not next next, but you know.
I get what you mean.
This room too?
This guy is taken care of everywhere.
How did he get in there?
Oh, we actually get to take the elevator down.
That's fun.
Uh oh, is he gonna be in there?
Okay.
Press the button.
I was expecting like a hand to reach in and stop it.
There's no...
There's no vents in this for him to climb through.
Oh god, here he is.
The priest!
Oh my god.
How did this happen?
No, no.
Oh no, no, no, no.
The priest came for him.
He was eavesdropping all this time to sneak in here when the door opens.
Some cameras are still working.
This is my corridor.
Oh no!
He's taking her upstairs.
Oh buddy.
Eating them beans.
There's reeks in here.
Hello my son.
What do you want?
I want to meet and talk.
You are going to run away from the wrath of god, but I can't allow that.
Sinners must be punished.
If you want her to survive, go up to the roof.
We have a serious conversation ahead of us.
No.
How do you see anything on these?
They are flipping so fast.
Oh, he's just an old man.
He's just an old guy.
Oh man, take the weapon.
He has nothing I can take it seems.
It doesn't seem like I can take anything.
Sorry.
No!
How did he...
It's so frustrating.
I wonder if I made the wrong decision somewhere.
Like if we can save him.
Ready your bubblegum.
Or are you going to rizz up the priest?
Alrighty.
Press the button.
It's so sad.
Give him the gum.
You're not you when you're hangry.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Hello?
Why are you going up?
He will kill you.
I need to save her.
Leave me alone!
Oh, you can tell me whatever you want.
I won't leave.
I'm faithful to you.
Oh my god, she's multiplying.
They all got what they deserve.
Their lies led to this.
And you made everything worse.
You risked yourself to get their approval.
I like how it's now question marks.
It's not the voice.
Don't let yourself get attached to someone.
And now you will suffer.
Don't answer.
You know I'm right.
You'll either die or end up alone.
He's already felt my mark on you.
He won't let you go.
Have you ever wondered why you don't see their faces?
It's not that it's not just an illness.
A barrier.
A shield from those who wish to stab you in the back.
So, everybody?
Secrets.
Vices.
Weaknesses.
Each of them.
The girl, the guard, the priest.
Which of them will stay with you?
Who can understand you?
No one.
Oh, they're all saying it.
Except me.
Got the three stooges up in here.
Leave me alone!
Oh.
Okay.
I'm getting hungry, guys.
And it's getting kind of late.
So I might go grab a snack real quick before we do the final part.
If that's okay.
Okay.
Go quickly.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I don't think this is time.
Just a quick, quick, quick, quick snack break so I can just not be so hungry and then I don't want to go to bed with a full tummy and then I'll have weird dreams about cosmic ladies.
Or, maybe that's my intention.
I don't know.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Om nom nom Nom nom nom Nom nom nom Nom nom nom Alright!
Let's go save our girl!
Look at this.
You don't have to flip all that this guy is...
He's just so extra.
You don't have to do all of this.
Come on, man.
Oh, there's a note.
Nom nom nom Nom nom C.A.
New guest.
Oh, wait.
Hm?
C.A.
New guest checked in today.
The guy came with just one backpack and rented a room for one day.
There's something strange about him.
He avoids people.
He wants to be alone.
He talks to himself.
He is quiet.
He is just like me.
Whoever...
Wait, who is writing these notes?
Yeah.
He's just like me.
For real, for real.
Oh.
Uh oh.
They flung you all the way over here.
Gosh, the nudists really did take over this hotel, didn't they?
Yeah, how would we have gotten the watcher up here?
Oh!
I wonder.
I fear.
This game reminds me of the Webtoon comic Sweet Home.
Oh, no one has mentioned that, but I actually...
I see it.
I do see it.
Especially because the people change into like the monsters that they kind of desire.
Yeah, it does.
Let her go!
Sweet Home is a game, right?
No, no, no.
It's a Webtoon comic.
You're thinking of...
Oh, I guess there was a game called Sweet Home, wasn't there?
Everything ends, my son.
Including our acquaintance.
Robin, are you okay?
Run away!
He went mad!
Oh my god, and your mic finally worked.
She's supposed to be quiet now.
Say one more word to her and she will die.
Oh my god.
Hey, do you know what's happening on April 24th?
Party time.
Oh!
Condemnation?!
Repent, my son.
Oh no!
Not April 30th?
No, it was the party on the flyer.
Was it April 24th?
What should I repent for?
Oh, he didn't like that.
I need bubble gum right now.
The first sin, my son.
Collusion with the devil.
What are you talking about?
He told you to shut up.
You don't have to make excuses.
I know the signs.
I have seen him many times these days.
The devil directs you with his words and says what you want to hear.
And you let him carry you away.
I've heard...
Maybe I shouldn't say that I've heard a voice.
But...
I don't know.
He's hearing voices too.
Also, this looks so epic.
I like the scenery.
Oh, my chat froze.
Three?
Heard a voice but I've never given into it.
Oh, he actually liked that.
You haven't stained your hands with the blood of the innocent.
Not yet.
But that doesn't mean you're guilty of something else.
Oh, you're not guilty of something else.
The second sin.
A bedding?
Blackjack?
Sorry that I gambled.
I'm sorry that I placed beds on the...
on the table.
You sheltered a runaway thief.
A traitor to her own family.
What will you say in your defense?
She didn't do anything wrong.
I didn't know anything about it.
She is guilty but she can repent.
Isn't his version of repent...
repenting just...
shooting them in the head though?
I don't think any of them repents, right?
One?
Betrayal of the family is the gravest of sins.
Your failure to recognize this makes your offense even worse.
Uh oh.
The third sin.
Fleeing from the holy duty.
I gave you a chance to survive.
You might not have noticed it.
But I tried to guide you on the right path.
I would have liked to see a person like you by my side.
To assist me in God's work.
And you decided to run away with the rest.
Just become another sheep in the flock.
I had no idea of your grand plans.
Wait, how do you know this?
There is no sin in being close to people.
I understand people and that's why I keep my distance.
I'll stay with you and help if you let her go.
Oh, this one is hard.
How do you know this though?
How does he know it?
But also, there is no sin in being close to people.
Let's do two.
Oh, he didn't like that.
There is no sin in being close to honest people.
But where do you see honest people?
Guys, I messed up!
Kneel my son.
It's time to say goodbye.
Are you ready?
Mommy!
I'm with you.
I'm always with you.
Let me in and I'll help.
Kill him?
No, no, no.
Close eyes.
I mean, I could kill him.
Good.
I think we got the bad end.
That scared me.
Oh no, we have to go through this again?
Hold on.
I messed up.
Let me refresh my YouTube.
I don't know why my chat freezes every stream.
He's gonna kill you.
Don't answer.
Don't ignore me.
You know I'm here.
They all got what they deserved.
You risked yourself.
I could still help her.
If you fail, both of you will die.
If you save her, she will leave you and break your heart.
Just like before.
He's already felt my mark on you.
Okay.
Let's go baby.
Alright.
I know I should have used my gum on the lady.
Had I known that you can't use your gum on the priest.
He doesn't have a sweet tooth you guys.
Chat freezes because chat is way too cool.
Everything ends my son.
Including our acquaintance.
I'll just say I came here to talk.
Good.
We have something to discuss.
Patience is not my virtue my child.
Don't test it.
I have worked hard for the glory.
My work is not done.
One confession.
Repent.
What should I repent for?
Oh, he hated that.
I forgot.
I thought that was what I was supposed to do.
Collusion with the devil.
No.
I forgot.
Oh god.
We are going to...
No.
I forgot.
That's why.
It's okay.
Where did we pick this one?
Yeah.
You haven't stained your hands.
For bedding.
I think it's three.
She is guilty but she can repent.
See?
I told you.
You guys chose one last time.
You allowed her to escape punishment simply because you hoped for her repentance.
I'm not guilty of anything.
It's this church that was exploiting us.
You disappoint me.
The third sin.
Fleeing from the holy duty.
I gave you a chance to survive.
You are on the right path.
What did I do before?
The no sin.
Being close to people.
I did two.
Yeah.
He didn't like two.
How do you know this?
You can't hide from our heavenly father.
He revealed your secrets to me.
I picked up the phone and I listened to your conversations.
Answer the question my son.
Do I sacrifice myself?
Oh no!
What's happening?
He's going to sacrifice himself.
Oh no!
Two or three.
A lot of you guys are saying two.
Okay I'll try two.
Oh he likes it.
Of course he does.
A worthy start but it's not enough.
Knowledge imposes responsibilities.
Yay!
I am in doubt my son.
You walked a worthy path but the voice of god commands me to carry out his punishment and his word is the law.
Forgive me.
How do you know that god is speaking to you?
Foolish question my son.
He knows all our secrets.
His words come true.
How can I not believe him?
You taught me yourself that you can't trust anyone.
But who could he be if not our father?
He guides me.
He's allowing me to carry out his justice.
Oh we're like... we're the table.
We're turntabling him.
He preaches what I've known all along.
Isn't it the devil who tells what people want to hear?
That's true but I've waited for this moment all my life.
I prayed for him to answer me.
I wanted to be his chosen one.
I trusted a deceiver.
There's only one way out.
Oh!
Forgive yourself and others.
No, this time I won't listen.
Sorry guys I have hiccups.
I'm trying not to hiccup.
This time I won't listen to you.
I've had enough strength to judge others.
I have enough strength to judge myself.
And if others don't deserve forgiveness then... Oh damn!
The priest!
May each be repaid according to his deeds.
I got an achievement.
I convinced the priest to let me live.
Oh!
The priest!
Wow, they built that so fast.
Do you trust people?
Wait, where do I go from here?
This way?
Oh yeah.
Oh my god!
You can see his face though.
Oh my god, you can see his face.
Alexander, thanks for the tank gifted!
Under the sea.
Oh, what's this one?
That's another tentacle.
I think.
Or is that the eel?
I am voice.
He's so cute.
I'm just a little eel in this apocalypse dream world.
I don't know why I'm even here.
I'm just an eel.
What is the point of my existence if I only exist in the dream realm?
I'm an eel.
This is so creepy.
Oh, him.
The watcher.
Oh, it's a telephone.
Pick up the phone.
I'm disabled.
I've watched people die.
Why is that his line?
That's so sad.
We're back in the hotel, but I don't think we really are.
Did this guy get out?
I hope so.
People in here are having a party.
Let's go.
It's like when we first got to the hotel.
I hear static in there.
No!
They graffitied over her alien.
I didn't like it.
I like how it's winking.
It's like, I'm an alien.
They ruined it.
Oh my god, they graffitied over my stuff too.
Wait, but this isn't where we had written it.
The note tongue was after our creepy writing.
Okay, 305.
We get it.
What happens now?
Good question.
I guess we drown.
She's here.
Hello, mom.
Welcome back.
Have a seat.
You must be tired, aren't you?
Would you like me to make some tea?
That would be great.
Sit down.
Just gonna sit.
Well done.
Relax.
There's nothing for you to worry about here.
I wanted to talk to you like this, directly, for so long, but your mind is such a stubborn thing.
It doesn't let anyone in.
It took a very long time before I could gather all the pieces to truly understand you.
And now, when we can really talk, I have an offer for you.
But first, I want to dispel your doubts.
What is happening to this world?
Are you in my head?
Why are you killing people?
What do you want from me?
I think I...
You want to know about one?
Okay, what's happening to the world?
I'm bringing a piece of my home with me.
I feel unwell without it.
Don't worry, it's a minor thing.
You'll get used to it.
No Artoons!
Oh, we get to ask all of these.
Why are you killing people?
I never harmed anyone.
All I do is bring love.
My friends simply stop those who prevent it from spreading.
Are you in my head?
Not quite.
I'm very far away.
But I can connect with those who are ready to answer me.
Some allow me to come and visit them.
Holy moly.
What do you want from me?
I don't want anything from you.
On the contrary, I want to help you.
I'll give you what I gave to others.
Happiness.
I came here for a reason.
At least she kept the couch.
Eight billion souls are suffering in purgatory.
How could I turn away from them?
It is alien.
She said she was far away, right?
I can give them happiness.
To each his own.
Unique.
As I've already given to others.
You turned people into monsters and make them your slaves.
You turned people into monsters.
They got what they wanted.
A new world inside their minds.
A new body.
The ability to charm.
To be part of someone's life.
To be invincible.
To punish.
They felt great.
Mankind ill needs a savior such as you.
An alien such as you.
What is a man?
Until you came.
Not everyone can be reached so easily.
Unfortunately, your mind is a stubborn one.
A rare quirk of perception that was combined with years of trauma and doubt.
Are you saying I have a quirk?
That's why you're so important.
If I become a part of you, I'll understand how to become a part of everyone else.
Your gifts are not material.
It's like madness.
Oh yeah, so what do you want in return?
Because I am curious about that.
The opportunity to help others.
That's all I ask.
Oh my gosh, she is a parasite.
She just wants to find other hosts.
I will wrap everyone in a blanket of dreams.
I just need to change a couple of things.
I need to remove those who hinder me.
I need to prepare the world for my arrival.
I feel your loneliness.
Even when you open up to others, they are not able to fully understand you.
But I can.
I hear Robin's voice.
I don't hear Robin's voice, do you?
I'm not going to trust you either.
Three, you guys want to go with Robin?
Because of a coincidence.
I tried to help you to open your mind so we could talk.
Unfortunately, it wasn't my voice that you began to hear first.
But when she leaves, everything will change.
You're still unsure.
I see it.
Alright, let me remind you of something.
The moment that started it all.
Are you jealous?
Are you obsessed with me, galactic mom?
I hear a heartbeat.
We're back at the hotel?
That's how you found her.
In the hotel.
How old were you then?
Five?
Six?
No father?
No friends?
Communication issues because of your condition?
There was only her in your world.
Yeah, I think she is supposed to be my mom.
Because the white lady...
She came to her as...
The voice came to her as her husband, so...
Then she decided to leave you.
Wasn't your mother supposed to be that person you could always rely on?
If she let you down, anyone can let you down.
Don't you dare talk about her like that.
You're trying to manipulate me.
I don't need her anymore.
Damn.
You're trying to manipulate me.
I've never deceived you and never let you down, unlike everyone else.
Why don't you believe me?
On one side, goth GF.
On the other, crazy eldritch mom.
Tough choice, huh?
Yeah.
Only a body in a flooded bathtub.
I wonder, is that why your dreams are always full of water?
So remember when he asked about the dreams, we almost said water.
But is it because of water?
Because we discovered our mom in the bath?
That's so messed up.
You're welcome to membership.
I know why you came to the hotel.
You thought about following her.
If you were ready to leave everything, why not join me instead?
I'm going back to Robin.
I'm sorry, but she's gone.
The helicopter has already arrived and she left you on the roof?
She wouldn't... she wouldn't.
Now you only have me... wait, no.
The time has come.
She's lying.
She has to be lying, right?
There is nothing around you.
No future, no past.
Oh, sorry.
I accidentally clicked.
There is only me.
And I can give you everything you want.
Are you ready to accept me?
Accept her?
No.
Let's go this way.
Don't leave.
I'll be with you.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, ma'am.
I don't want what you're selling.
There is nothing waiting for you there.
Stay.
I don't want what you're selling.
I don't need it.
Oh my god, she's actually starting to sound like a real creature.
Oh my god.
What if I go... oh, it only lets me go in a little certain path.
She disappeared.
Oh no, there she is.
Bye!
I wonder what happens if you accept her.
I'm so glad you woke up.
Put
the mosaic back.
That's a Beauty and the Beast moment.
That's a Beauty and the Beast moment for real.
Bring the Beast back.
Excerpts from the diary of the commander of the 3rd Rescue Service Brigade.
September... Oh no!
The girl from the Hotel Robin came in today to thank us before leaving.
She wants to make sure her family is okay.
The elderly professor was with her.
Apparently he plans to look after her.
Oh my god.
We were flying over the city and noticed several survivors on the roof.
They say that some young man led them out and left.
This is very strange.
Every major city I've heard of has had an outbreak.
It is no longer possible to contain it.
We were ordered to take survivors to quarantine zones.
We were able to save only around 15% of the state's population.
I pray for us every day.
I hope that I'll be heard.
Sorry, I didn't realize that it was changing text.
Did we stay behind?
September 24th... I don't think we got a precise date, did we?
Oh!
That's it!
But we... But we beat the illness!
Lindsay!
Oh wow!
You told her to.
I thought we would change our minds.
Damn.
What was this about the elderly man?
What did it say?
Sorry, I missed it.
We lost the girl to save the world.
We're heroes!
Man in 311.
Oh, the professor.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We had the guy.
We had the guy in 311.
So what?
311 and her are the only two that escaped?
Damn.
What about the other endings?
I wonder if it will let us...
I'm just gonna... If I continue...
I don't really want to go from the elevator.
OK.
Oh!
Good, good, good.
We can try the ending where we... where we accept her.
Let's see.
If you beat the illness, why didn't you go with?
Yeah, I don't understand.
We should see what happens if we choose to go.
That was a long time ago that we chose that though.
Alright.
Let's just pick different options.
I don't need her anymore.
You're right, but if you chase me away, the loneliness will return.
It will always come back.
Oh, whoops.
I know why you came to the hotel.
What are you suggesting?
I've already said.
Happiness.
I'll replace her.
The time has come.
OK, here we go.
Let's just accept her and see what happens.
No option to redo major choices.
But it's OK.
No future, no past, no one to rely on.
OK, let's accept her.
Let's see what happens.
Thank you.
I promise you will be happy.
If we don't even get to go with Robin, then what's the point?
Everyone will be happy.
All that's left is to cut off everything that's in our way.
Oh my god.
But we're messed up.
Oh, but we're really messed up.
Oh my god.
Put the mosaics back on.
We transformed!
The helicopter is like, nope, nope.
Distress signal was received from the quarters of the Sanity Inn.
Rescue helicopter arrived.
No survivors were found.
Oh my god.
They were like, we're out of here.
The number of attacks has dramatically increased over the past few days.
We've lost contact with Washington.
We're currently transporting survivors to the nearest military base.
We're unsure that where else might be safe.
There are rumors circulating that nuclear weapons have been deployed on several outbreak areas.
If this is true, the explosions didn't help.
The world is in flames.
We can't hold on.
Oh my god.
Not even 15% survival.
Just the world.
That's it.
Today I had a peculiar dream.
Oh my god.
Good end?
No.
I think that's the least good end.
Damn.
Just because you gave in.
I must have been so special.
But I remember she said if she learns how to accept me...
Or learns how to get into my mind...
Then she would learn how to be into anybody's mind.
So it seems like...
Because we didn't give in, then she was like...
I don't know how to get into everyone.
So maybe...
Maybe that's why it was...
It was the fact that we survived.
Or if we give in, she's able to take over the whole planet.
Wow.
Yeah, we're built different for real.
That was so fun.
Oh my gosh, the game has such a good atmosphere.
Some of the jumpscares were maybe a little cheap, but...
Overall, I feel like they did a good job with it.
And the story was intriguing.
Not really horror so much.
Yeah, it was more spooky than anything else.
And I'm glad that...
None of the... You know what indie horror games always have an issue with?
Is the monsters, the things that you fight are always like...
Frustratingly difficult, but here it was like...
I don't want to say it was too easy, but it was like...
It didn't feel like I was struggling, you know?
Like, oh my gosh, I just...
Is there a way to save the guard?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Had it in the background, but got really invested at the end.
They used themes pretty well.
The choices are not super obvious, you really think stuff out.
Yeah!
It actually was very...
I liked the choices very much.
It was very...
I felt like for some of them I could have gone with several options.
I liked it a lot.
But...
This game unironically captures what having a goth GF is like.
Yeah, we're special!
Thanks for the stream, I hope everyone gets a goth GF on their own someday.
Oh yeah, just, you know...
I know you couldn't get Robin, but...
Just for the end of the stream.
Thanks for the stream, Rinto!
Really fun and intriguing story for an early access game.
Feels like a finished product already.
It felt...
Like they definitely have the story and everything.
Like I said, there were some graphical glitches sometimes, but...
It wasn't anything so distracting.
Joyprincess, thank you!
Yeah.
I had a lot of fun, I hope you guys did too.
I didn't see very many Vtubers playing this one, so...
Maybe if someone else plays it, they'll do like goofy answers.
It's hard for these types of games when you're just like...
Oh, I wanna do the bad answers.
Because I wanna just be a little jerk, but...
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
But then, you know, when you want to see what the good ending is...
You're like, I gotta choose the good ending, you know?
Cause chaos can be fun.
Yeah, I can.
But today I was like, I'm gonna be a good guy.
Today, I'm the good guy.
I'm riding.
My new Oshi is made like that.
NOOOOOO!
But you said I was your Kamiyoshi.
Good job resisting the bad choices.
Thank you!
Yeah.
This is fun though.
Thanks guys for hanging out with me.
I know, like I said, this was a bit of a longer game.
Oops, sorry.
I just clicked out.
But that was a lot of fun to play!
I hope you guys liked it.
I will see you guys when I see you next.
And...
Yeah.
Hold on.
Oh, I forgot something for...
Here we go.
Bye or whatever.
Get out.
Go home.
Go home now.
Get out.
Bye!
Bye bye.
No
way.
The Minecraft movie is gonna be on April 4th?
No.
Everything that they keep releasing about it makes me look forward to it less and less.
Everything is just so bad.
The skeletons are ugly.
The zombies are ugly.
The beaches are ugly.
The wolves are ugly.
Everything is ugly!
No!
I don't want the Minecraft movie to happen anymore!
Cancel it!
Cancel the Minecraft movie!
No!